justin trudeau tells the truckers that
you gotta get off that bridge or else
he threatens to send in the military and
the truckers vote we are not leaving joe
biden offered help assistance or i
should say that the bud administration
offered to help intervene to shut down
these protests and i got to say
that means it's working and it's obvious
it's working and they have no answer to
it they need violence when they don't
know how to handle non-violent civil
disobedience from just people sitting in
the road they freak out they panic they
threaten they can't do anything because
if the government comes in with a heavy
hand against peaceful protesters it will
ignite a mass movement against them we
saw it during occupy wall street so
we're going to talk about all that we'll
talk about what's going on with uh the
latest the freedom convoy and we also
have this this is a crazy story
adam kinzinger
said that if a civil war is to break out
and he thinks it's possible there will
be targeted assassinations
you know the rhetoric on i think this
was msnbc he was saying this mainstream
tv it's getting absolutely crazy so
we're going to talk about that we're
going to talk about foreign policy
ukraine and joining us to discuss all of
this is corey mills how's it going man
thanks for coming i'm good thanks for
having me do you want to introduce
yourself yeah so corey mills i'm
actually running for congress for
florida seventh district uh former
combat veteran business owner father
husband uh and just all around good guy
right on true very simple well very
simple used to be a contributor on on
newsmax there's anything else you wanted
i did so i was
a media contributor i was a dod advisor
for the trump administration so i was an
appointee there um
so i used to write a lot with with
foreign policy stuff over the last 10
years
in particular like the middle east stuff
so i did a lot on you know covering
iran's movements geopolitical stuff that
was going around uh i've spent almost
seven years in iraq i spent over three
years in afghanistan and pakistan i was
in ukraine in 2015 when the russians
were coming across or pro separatists as
they like to call it in donetsk
so yeah traveled around a little bit uh
seeing a little things right on thanks
for coming man we got seamus seamus
coughlin of freedom tunes i run a
youtube channel called freedom tunes
where we create animated political
satire if you guys wanna go check some
of that out we released a video two days
ago that people seem to be enjoying that
i think your audience would love it's
called fed talks oh yeah very good
what's up everybody ian crossland over
here happy to see you corey great to
talk to you man looking forward to this
i was talking to corey before the show
he's exceedingly knowledgeable in all of
the areas we talk about it's going to be
a great conversation tonight i'm really
looking forward to it before we get
started everybody head over to
timcast.com and become a member
it's not just about the member segments
that you get access to you know we had
marjorie taylor green and thomas massion
for a great members only segment but
it's also that you will be supporting
our journalists you help make this show
possible and it's sort of the the pay
what you will model if you if you like
the news that our journalists are
writing we got a shout out from matt
walsh today it was it was matt right
yeah it was that was cool yeah he was
reading one of our articles so i i
greatly appreciate that membership is
what makes all of this work so
timcast.com become a member and you can
watch all of the exclusive members only
podcast but don't forget to smash that
like button one like equals one honk
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends let's get to that
first big story yo the threat of the
military is back
daily mail reports freedom convoy votes
to stay on the bridge and defy trudeau's
order to clear it by 7 pm the prime
minister threatened that everything is
on the table including using the
military after a call with biden to
discuss americans backing the protest
this is this is an insane escalation
first of all when i read this morning
that joe biden
contacted canada the administration was
like we're going to help you with this
and you got to shut it down i was like
wow
somebody tweeted that the u.s should
invade canada i mean i know i tweeted
that but someone tweeted it before me
and i it's a joke right we're not gonna
but now i mean the idea that the us
would get involved in a canadian protest
but like we talked about it could be
payback for the 1819 invasion right
that's it mm-hmm yeah
was like now's our chance well i mean he
was around he saw it happen that's
exactly right
yeah
this is like an example of them trying
to shut down something that's trying to
shut down something that's trying to
shut down something you know they're
trying to shut down the combos trying to
shut down the government which is trying
to shut down the people's access to
their stuff but i love the fact that you
know biden and the dems they want to get
involved and try and shut down this in
canada but yet where were they during
the 2020 riots when they're out there
encouraging it and they're out there
saying we should get in the face of
politicians and we should why isn't
there more widespread civil unrest i
mean this was the rhetoric they were
using back then because it was
beneficial to them and now all of a
sudden it was like no no we have to be
interventionist exactly it's because it
works it's because they say these things
and their voter base doesn't change that
that people will keep voting for them is
is astonishing to me well and the fact
that that we we've seen i mean look
secretary gates who was the secretary of
defense under the obama biden
administration you know he had that live
interview and they asked him about joe
biden in foreign policy he said look joe
biden's the only person i know he's been
100 wrong on foreign policy i mean this
is his own secretary of defense right so
now you've got him doing the exact same
thing and democrats they constantly talk
about you know interventionism i mean
look at us we're involved in russia
ukraine now we're now looking at getting
involved in canada but why can't we even
secure our own american borders and
focus on an america first agenda
thinking about our people first that's
what i have a question about i think the
rest of the american people do as well
yeah ever since we started i mean i
don't know how you feel about the
federal reserve and the whole
international banking car i don't know
if you called a cartel or a scheme or
what like the bank of international
settlements in switzerland it goes
through the the federal reserve of new
york the bank of england and the bank of
australia and then basically seems to be
it's a swiss ba it's going through a
swiss bank that's not an american thing
and so i i have a feeling they just
don't really care about american
democracy american people are a
byproduct and well well i correct people
on this by the way i i hate when
everyone wants to say oh america is the
longest serving democracy no
correct everyone who says this we are a
constitutional republic
people need to understand the difference
between what it is to be a democracy and
what it is to be a a constitutional
republic we have democratic elections
but we are a constitutional republican i
always not to interrupt but i always
like to try and correct people on that
because you know that's a really big
deal are we a democratic republic
no we are a constitutional republic we
are based if you're a true you know what
i consider to be an american who is a
constitutionalist who believes in our
freedoms values and things that we stand
for the things that we're supposed to be
protecting which is why we have a
military and things like this then you
understand what it is to be a
constitutional republic we have
democratic processes but we are actually
a constitutional republican because
within the republic they use democracy
to decide yes or no yeah well we elect
our representatives that's the
democratic process and then they decide
the yes or no through a democratic
process again the reason they do this
trick it's a language trick it always is
and it works
they keep saying our democracy our
democracy because they want a direct
democracy right because a direct
democracy is easy to manipulate 100
percent i guess
look at this way
let's say you have
a hundred people
and there's there's there's four
different categories of political
ideology a b c and d
you need only win
two of those
factions plus one to control the system
that means that group a might be in
favor of policies one and two group b
could be in favor of policies three and
four
you can come out and advocate against
one of the group's interests as long as
you convince another group so basically
it's kind of you know i don't know if
people can follow me on this one the
idea is direct democracy you will have a
majority unhappy population and you will
be able to control them and they can't
do anything about it i'll give you
actually here's a simple example
this is what i was told about egypt
during the second revolution
the reason it happened was because there
were there was uh like eight political
parties or something like that
and the muslim brotherhood made up like
20 percent of the country a minority but
because of the way they do their
elections
they got the most votes of any group the
country is then ruled by the minority so
it's not the exact same election system
it's the same thing in iraq and it's the
same thing that's why you continue to
see this political turmoil because what
happens the very people who tried to
overthrow the government then say well
wait a second that doesn't work through
force we'll create a political party and
get enough people that support us in the
elections and then they basically take
over a sectarian democracy
yep
yeah we don't we don't want direct
democracy i've seen it i've seen it play
out it's uh it results in the in the
impoverished marginalized people being
severely oppressed and anyone who claims
otherwise is outright lying to you and
that's why we have an electoral college
that's why we are a republic and to
quote benjamin franklin though it may be
apocryphal he said democracy or he said
democracy is two wolves and a lamb
voting on what's for lunch a republic is
a well-armed lamb contesting the vote no
i mean it's true a direct democracy is
really just a i would say a cleaner
more systematized version of mob rule
well so let's let's talk about this in
the context of what's happening in
canada then if you've got uh you know so
so trudeau says it's a fringe minority
and the media comes out so it's only 500
truckers it's a fringe minority now some
have said it's 50 000 truckers i mean
either way 50 000 it's a lot of people
but not relative to the 30 plus million
citizens of canada so is that a problem
then
as as populations grow denser and denser
you need a smaller smaller and smaller
percentage of the population to enact
change through even nonviolence of
disobedience
now is that fundamentally wrong well you
see it on twitter the density of our
interactions have have concluded or have
condensed uh on online in social
networking we're all packed together now
and you see a small fringe group of
psychopaths can completely warp the
narrative overnight that's very
dangerous but it seems like it's also
human nature so so i have something we
just gotta have to deal with it coming i
mean this is this is the challenge of
our life or one of i mean i personally i
don't really see it there's a big
problem with this i mean look they're
they're doing a non-violent protest it's
it's their right i mean look if this is
in america the one of the things that
you know i fought for when i was in
uniform was for our constitutional
liberties and freedoms and one of that
is freedom of speech and freedom to
protest and freedom you know i'm not
talking about the types of quote-unquote
protests that the democrats were
labeling when they were thinking that
rioting and tearing down chanel stores
in downtown new york on fifth avenue was
was was protesting i mean or i always
loved that that picture where it's like
the cnn guy with the fire like blazing
behind him he's like well it's a mostly
peaceful protest
fiery but mostly
[Music]
at the end of the day i think that it is
very healthy and i think that i enjoy
the fact when america or any nation
rises together to show just like with us
that we are the majority we the people
not we the government i think that
something that is really inspiring and
something that i was you know was worth
fighting for because that's what we want
to maintain is those freedoms liberties
and rights it's a good day you know
constantly seeing the victories of these
truckers
there was a there's a viral post going
around we've talked about it how um
you know people are saying it's a
workers uprising why is the left opposed
to this because the mask is off
the left they're fascists they're
overtly fascist they're pro-corporate
pro-government they've always been they
just didn't like that donald trump was
the person in charge of one branch one
branch
and and he barely could could anything
done because of the muck in the mire and
the sludge in the swamp not to say that
everything he did was good he did some
bad things and it wasn't just a love
attack number you had the republicans
who were part of the establishment part
of the swamp who are also stabbing them
in the back i mean the very people who
was riding the coattails of president
trump's conservative movement are the
same people who are secretly stabbing
him behind because they wanted to
maintain status quo and why because they
were getting paid off by big lobby they
were getting help by corporate they
weren't really wanting the america first
agenda they wanted the power elite
status quo that they had yep i was
thinking a few days ago about corruption
and then i thought i think we need
corruption in the system if you have a
system with no corruption that means
it's an authoritarian crackdown on
everything i disagree
i i actually think the problem with
authoritarianism is not so much that you
have a strong authority structure it's
that the people on top don't have to
follow any of those rules
and you know the funny part a lot of
times it's not even that you know
someone's doing something which is quote
unquote corrupt what they're doing is
they're finding the great areas to
continue to live upon and they basically
go well i never gave money to x i gave
it to y and y gave it to z and z gave it
to b and you know they try to find these
little loopholes and i think those are
the things that you know governments are
spending more time on looking at
legislation that one improves the
betterment of life i'm all about limited
government about limited taxes and
freedom of speech and our second
amendment rights et cetera et cetera but
you know at the end of the day what i
want to see is this government who are
basically shutting down these loopholes
and not spending 90 of their time
sitting there just voting on
continuation bills yeah maybe there's
evil corruption and good corruption like
if you have a computer software program
it's a virus and it's destroying
everything and you corrupt the virus is
that like a good lineup
yeah if you corrupt the virus program
and it no longer works then you've
stopped the virus you did good
corruption to a system
i'm not sure about that no we were
talking about this earlier destruction
can be a good thing so for instance
we're talking about is it right to kill
you know even a bug or an animal well
sometimes you go hunting because the
deer population grows to goes out of
control you cull the the herd otherwise
they would destroy the ecosystem and
then everyone suffers yeah so sometimes
you have to you know yeah and i talked
about this with regards to trophy
hunting as an example right so i went
out and people were saying like how how
cruel it is to kill these you know large
trophy elks things like that what they
don't realize is is that a lot of times
you killing those elks at their prime is
the most humane thing you can do because
what ends up happening is a younger buck
essentially challenges them kicks them
out and they end up wandering by
themselves alone until they end up
falling dead so you know look there's uh
something to be said about this i mean i
grew up in a very kind of i guess just
above the poverty level you know kind of
family and so hunting for us was a
staple in order to fill our deep freeze
i mean
bus buying 150 deep freeze to put on our
back patio was a lot cheaper than trying
to buy the meat that we would require
for the whole year yeah and also if you
if you go hunting what you're doing is
refusing to subsidize factory farming in
a lot of instances and so people talk
all day and night about how cruel we
treat our animals in this country for
the most reality is yeah but but also on
top of that i mean hunting if it's an
animal you're going to eat is one of the
most humane ways to obtain it because
like you said you're preventing a far
more cruel death i think a lot of people
have illusions about what nature is
actually like because they've never
spent any time in it oh my gosh and it's
not beautiful or i mean it is
beautiful it's very painful yeah it's
beautiful exactly it's beautiful but it
it's very painful and so yeah hunting an
animal giving them a quick death so that
you can consume them i mean you have
people
they literally think that you know uh
food is just wrapped in a package and
sat in a grocery store i mean we're so
removed from the process of agriculture
i mean i think that's the biggest thing
and i'm a huge agriculture advocate
right so i'm one of those guys i believe
that food security and national security
goes hand in hand i think that we need
to look at more production domestically
i think we need to support agricultural
sector here domestically and i think
that stopping like drop shipments and
importations that are actually you know
hurting our local farmers is not part of
the america first agenda but you know
again people are too far removed from
what it is to have a proper food like
source yeah i'm not sure i'm sure you
guys may have seen this but if not i'll
bring it to your attention years ago i
believe this is from the 80s there's a
newspaper clipping from that era which
which sort of went viral at that time
and it is still floating around but it
was somebody writing into a newspaper
and they said i couldn't believe that
you published an op-ed from a hunter he
should have just gone to the grocery
store and gotten his food
from people who didn't harm animals to
get it which is hysterical
but i mean i hear what you're saying
about food security
and i think part of the problem is
people in power again they know that if
the food becomes more scarce they're not
going to be the one starving to death
which is sort of what i was alluding to
earlier ian when i said the issue isn't
necessarily an authority structure it's
when the people at the top are above the
authority structure and they don't have
to follow the rules i think when they're
on the same playing field as the average
person they're much more cautious about
which laws they're willing so maybe
corrupt is forcing people to become
corrupt to change that corruption or
whatever okay i see what you're saying
well let's talk about another big
problem authoritarianism and one of the
big problems is stupidity when you have
an authoritarian system that allows
really stupid people who lack merit to
be on top they do really really dumb
things and they use force to impose
really dumb things that break the system
which brings me to this tweet
by juliet km juliet is a harvard
professor
remember that point and a cnn analyst
ceo of grip mobility she tweets the
convoy protest applauded by right-wing
media as a freedom protest is an
economic and security issue now the
ambassador bridge link can link
constitutes 20 of annual trade between
us and canada slash the tires empty gas
cans arrest the drivers and move the
trucks now i'd like to just um
start with some
rudimentary math
slash the tires
empty the gas cans arrest the drivers
and move the trucks how do you propose
to move the trucks after you've slashed
their tires after the gas cans and
arrested the drivers and how do you and
how do you actually start moving and
actually shipping things from coast to
coast or across the borders if you don't
have actual trucks to do it in she says
it constitutes 28 of annual trade
because of the truckers
wow see this is why i um you got to be
really careful about despotism and
authoritarianism because this is a
harvard professor yeah telling people
this my response to this was it's no
wonder they think two plus two equals
five right they can't do basic logical
steps it was like it was like joe
biden's infrastructure bill it's gonna
cost us zero and then all of a sudden it
was like how does trillions of dollars
cost us zero but that's their math they
they want it to sound that way even
though they know it's not that way when
he was saying us he was referring to
like himself and his political allies
it's not gonna cost us anything yeah you
guys will pay that bill yeah we're
taking it from your pocket so i saw the
word security up here it makes me
nervous talking about national security
before the show because it's become such
an integral part of our society this
word this concept nationals didn't exist
before 2003. no one ever talked about it
they used 911 in this war in iraq to
justify
be afraid be afraid be afraid and we
need to secure you let us secure you and
now they're yelling out oh it's
threatening my security like come on but
but let me just stress real quick once
again the security threat is the trade
but it's the truckers who facilitate
that trade that she's threatening it's
like it's it's a security issue if we
can't have trade so go after those who
facilitate it yeah i mean
what is there ever a thank you is there
ever thank you to the people who brought
you your food and all of these
unbelievably important things that we
have to trade to have a sustainable
economy no well people are seeing it now
though aren't they i mean look every one
of our restaurants or our grocery stores
are on forced diets i mean we see the
supply chain issues we're seeing ships
moored off on the coast that you know
they can't actually come on we see like
the entire breakdown while pete budaje
you know goes on vacation and we can't
get everything you know locked down but
but you're right i mean the very people
who want to attack
those responsible for transporting all
of those or saying you're impacting our
ability to supply well let's slice your
towel oh well how's that going to help
exactly well like an autoimmune disease
how do you destroy
diseases but treating the symptom
without recognizing the disease well and
i want to make a point here she's
referring to these workers standing up
for themselves as a security issue
because that makes it more difficult for
us to have a functioning economy so
if making it more difficult to have a
functioning economy is a security issue
then the most violent psychopaths we're
aware of are all in government because
currently our national debt is at 30
trillion dollars and as of january 31st
2022 that is 90 000 of debt for every
living person in the u.s i just want to
say this if there was a group of rioters
or radicals who caused so much damage to
the country that it totaled 30 trillion
dollars we would lock them up and throw
away the key public perception would be
completely against them and yet we
praise the state and when people stand
up for themselves and say they're not
going to take it anymore we demonize
them and call them the security threat
we don't the cult does it's true and so
that's why my attitude's lately just
been like yo i don't take these people
seriously especially like if you look at
my twitter as of tonight i've just been
having so much fun oh i've seen it it's
been fun to read yeah tim messaged me at
8 30 this morning like what if we've
been taken over by my space mind worms
i'm like he's in the right mode right
now
so ian's always got good crazy yeah he's
like tim rolled to 20. i was watching no
no it's because i was watching some
sci-fi camera what it was where um i was
watching uh a piece peacemaker i haven't
seen it
so uh well then i can't spoil it that's
cena is that cena john cena yeah john
cena um
man i guess this is a partial spoiler if
you've been watching the series so
you've been warned i'll give you a few
more seconds i'm gonna say it again uh i
was watching peacemaker i think it's a
great show
and a component of the show is aliens
taking over people's bodies so i
messaged ian and i was like what if the
aliens are invading the earth and that's
why they're telling everybody you've got
to go out and get the injections i'm
thinking
well just to be fair the dod did
unclassify what was it last year or
something that that they did actually
have you know unidentified flying
objects it didn't it was during the
riots during the code lockdown i feel
like everyone's like had bigger issues
they're like yeah whatever you know ufos
yeah they're out of the way they're here
i'm ready to go out i think it might be
well if it's anything maybe it's like
have you ever seen kymatics where like
they vibrate um a membrane with sand on
it and then they did the depending on
the frequency it makes these crazy
shapes if you look it up on youtube it's
getting sound waves and i wonder if
we're being bombarded by vibration from
extraterrestrial sources that are
causing us to act
we're being bombarded by
ignorance sound waves and that's mostly
coming from the left it's coming from
the tv it's coming from cable
mainstream yeah mainstream media but
hold on i i so ian i wouldn't call that
rolling a one
i would say that um i like the analogy
imagine you've got you know brian
stelter and rachel maddow and they're
both on two different tvs with their
resident frequencies of fake news
garbage and it's making regular people
lose their minds i have put on i took
like five of my own youtube videos and
turned them all on at the same time and
started listening and it was really
soothing i highly recommend it
you guys should all try it
no i'm good the more videos the better i
have a feeling to put on like a thousand
videos that sounds like music like ocean
waves and music or something i wanted to
go back to a point that you're bringing
up and we discussed it earlier but
talking about this national deficit that
we're looking at i mean the 30 trillion
plus dollars and i wanted to you know
one of the things we were discussing was
that a lot of people are incorrectly and
tim you mentioned something earlier
about using the wrong language and you
know people are always talking about oh
we want a balanced budget we want a
balanced budget but i don't think they
understand what that actually means i
mean that would mean rapid hyper
taxation etc etc i think what people are
really trying to say what we need to
control over is one yes we need physical
conservativity but what we need is we
need to ensure that our gdp to debt
ratio is basically what is balanced this
is modern monetary theory like you can
spend as much as you want as long as
you're going to create more profits
that's exactly right and one of the ways
that we are able to continue to thrive
is again to go back to the america first
agenda of looking at domestic production
looking at the ideas of controlling like
president trump did where we had oil
independency you know we weren't
approving other people's oil pipelines
like nordstrom 2 for russia who's
economically advancing themselves and
ingratiating themselves with germany who
they control all their oil and gas we
had our own independence of this i mean
you think about it in 2017 you know in
october we were only importing like 21
000 barrels from russia
this october this past one we imported
216 000 barrels from russia so if you
look at that we are literally with china
and russia china always says is the
greatest existential threat but when you
look at this we're literally funding and
economically advancing our adversarial
nations while increasing our spending
and not controlling our gdp to debt
ratio i think it's on purpose
of course it is yeah donald trump was
like let's not do this and joe biden was
like let's do it also i i just want to
make a point here with respect to mmt
i'm against that for a number of reasons
but one of the primary ones is we sort
of saw a de facto mmt with the
government printing trillions of dollars
over the past couple years and i don't
trust them to have any more influence
over the economy than they already have
the way the constitution's written is
congress is supposed to control the
money but instead they offloaded the the
responsibility to the federal reserve
when they kind of secretly created it
over christmas now if we gave the
control back to khan are you saying you
still be uncomfortable with congress in
control of it yeah well i'm
uncomfortable with mmt in general for a
number of reasons it's a really
complicated topic but one of the issues
with it is they argue we can print as
much money as we want and we won't have
inflation as long as the economy grows
at an equal pace to the amount of money
that we're getting this is the
difficulty there this is the
ratio one of the difficulties with that
though is then you have to depend upon
the government to generate the proper
work programs in order to get people
fully employed while they're producing
all this money this is where i think
it's the falsity i you know like
president reagan used to say that the
scariest words ever is that we're here
from the we're from the government we're
here to help yeah i mean look the
reality is that americans create america
jobs you know the every time that the
government has tried to come in and
build our economy or stop unemployment
or things like this they have failed
massively and they've only served to do
things like bailing out of solyndra you
know remember remember obama's solyndra
the 1.1 billion dollar scheme basically
which was look
the the government needs to get out and
stop over-regulating american businesses
and allow us you know that was a great
thing about president trump's tax reform
i know as a business owner that we were
able to take that money and bring on
more people in the state of florida to
work for us and that enabled us to do
more with our money and that's exactly
what government is supposed to be doing
isn't enabling you not over regulating
you yeah absolutely when this is
interesting because you were sort of
mentioning earlier
an increase in taxes in order to balance
the budget but what a lot of people
don't consider is the fact that tax cuts
can actually generate more revenue and
the trump tax cut was an example of that
the media repeatedly said that we ended
up with an increased deficit because of
those tax cuts but that's not true we
ended up with a five percent surplus
over what we were expected to have but
we spent ten percent more i liked it and
that's why we had to do with that money
by the way which was brilliant he took
some of our extra and additional money
and he plus back up our oil reserves did
you see what biden did when he came back
in he actually sold some of our oil
reserves to china wow amazing i mean i
like i like to explain this with a story
um many of you may have heard many of
you may not obviously i've told it
before but um
a friend of mine a friend of mine's dad
was explaining to me why raising taxes
had hurt tax revenue in cook county
chicago basically and what happened was
they increased the tax by like a
fraction of a percent they ended up
losing a ton of money because it's
the example given to me was he's like
i'm a contractor i'm going to go to home
depot and i'm going to do a big order
it's going to be thousands of dollars
the end of the year i got to calculate
how much i spend at home depot every
time i went in for supplies
when they raise the taxes that could be
twenty thousand dollars if i drive an
extra ten miles takes a little bit of
time out of my day i save twenty grand
i'm gonna do it absolutely that means
the revenue is going to a different
county correct so raising the taxes
they lost money yeah and so left winger
will often scoff at the idea of the
laffer curve and they'll even call it
pseudoeconomics the reality is no
competent economist on the left or right
denies the existence of the laffer curve
left-wing economists tend to say that
parabola peaks at a higher tax rate so
they'll say you can tax as much as 70 in
certain sectors and you won't end up
negatively affecting revenue i think
that's ridiculous conservatives tend to
say it's more 20 but interestingly
enough
the amount of revenue the federal
government has pulled in has generally
hovered around 20 regardless of what the
tax rate was well you know i was
thinking about something um just with
everything that's been going on
especially with uh the the establishment
left opposition to the convoys and
everything we really are in an era where
if one side is for something the other
side is against it which is really
dangerous it leads us to serious
conflict you know uh the alec baldwin
story is a good one alec baldwin
should have checked the gun this should
be a grand slam for the left who says we
need gun control and regulations but now
all of a sudden they're like alec
baldwin did nothing wrong by not
checking a gun and shooting them into
the chest it's crazy so i started
thinking about it i'm like maybe we
should roll their own yeah well maybe we
should roll with it and then when they
say tax the rich we say text the poor
attack attacks the poor
that's right
inflation is essentially you know
invisible taxation and we were talking
about this earlier
specifically i mean the middle class is
the one who takes it the most right
because that's what they're looking at
look there's one economical principle i
can guarantee and this is the principle
why socialism doesn't work you cannot
multiply wealth by dividing it that's a
simple amen common thing all right so
but what they continue to do is they
think that i can't get certain tax
regulations or tax legislations you know
in because we don't have the majority in
the senate we're at a 50-50 and i can't
necessarily get it passed because people
won't take it on for the left so what
they do is they just continue to print
money and it's just taxation through
inflation which is exactly what they're
looking for or defunding of our military
which we talked about earlier you see
that cnn article that was like inflation
is good for poor people and bad for rich
people
it's it's look it's it's the hunger
games for everyone that article uh but
it's substantially worse for the poor
that's right that article was i'm like
watching the hunger games and stanley
tucci sitting up on stage going don't
worry inflation is bad for the rich
people
i'm like if you're rich you can convert
your your scary good by the way yeah oh
yeah that's scary if you're rich you can
convert your cash into real estate into
gold into bitcoin into hard assets and
if you're poor you can't it's or should
say that's right you can't it's just
substantially harder so every day your
bank account has lower and lower buying
power rich people are like about a
painting yeah exactly well and
interestingly enough inflation is
literally as flat as attacks can get
everyone loses the exact same percentage
of spending power off of every dollar
they have you made a point earlier about
not being able to uh multiply wealth by
dividing it and i think there's one
exception and i believe you'll agree
with it based on what you've said but
there is one way to multiply wealth by
dividing it which is just through
voluntary trade and people who own their
own businesses making the decision to
spend in specific places so that their
money goes to somebody who's making a
product that adds wealth to the economy
but when it comes the federal government
doing it they're completely inept you
could
to grow wealth by dividing it like one
would be like if you're with a bunch of
people in a tribe and they don't have
shoes but you need to go hunting you
could give give everybody a little
pair of shoes of yours that's
distributing your wealth and now they
can all go hunting and they're going to
be better at it and so that's that's
called an investment though that's
exactly right so that's different so
giving but what if they gave them money
and that's also done by the people and
for the people you know it's not
government basically just printing out
dollars for their own agendas
but let me let me give you a better
example i do like where you're at on
this idea you know that that you could
have a bunch of shoes give them out and
then everyone is better off but the
problem is what our government is doing
is a tribe of people and one guy has you
know five pairs of shoes everybody else
has one and there's one guy with no
shoes so the chief comes in takes four
of the pairs of shoes from the rich guy
and then sells them to pay for pakistani
gender studies yeah well 25 million
actually but but remember that was
technically though this is why i love
let me tell you the democrats have
gotten brilliant about the labeling of
bills and and like for example the bill
you're talking about the america rescue
bill where 25 million dollars goes to
pakistan for gender research programs
how does that help the average america i
know myself i was sitting at home
thinking god i really wish my money
could go to gender research in pakistan
yeah yeah i was really concerned and
here's the question that nobody asks
about this kind of thing
in some circumstances you might be able
to argue that foreign aid is a
legitimately charitable thing to do but
can you name a single country that went
from a developing country to a developed
country because the united states
government threw enough money at it when
has it ever worked well in afghanistan
yeah yeah look at that
yeah wow
that's a touchy one i mentioned it to
thomas massey i was like why don't we
just instead of giving a borrowing from
the federal reserve giving it to another
country why don't they just borrow it
from this from the reserve but what i
should have said is just why don't they
borrow it from their own central bank
and leave us out of it and then accrue
their own debt why do we have to they
they don't have so like in the instance
of a
instance of afghanistan they don't have
the resources or wealth to trade with
other countries for advanced technology
and development well but what about
china who just came in there and they're
looking to harvest 1.3 trillion of
lithium and who are they going to sell
those renewable batteries back to
america yeah yeah so i mean again there
there all of these countries have for
the for the most part something i mean
people are like oh well what do they
have in uh can your somalia well they
got oil you know we saw that in lake
lake turkana around that area so you
know it's the same thing with
afghanistan you know they're like oh
something about rocks while it's got 1.3
trillion dollars first off in in lithium
not to mention that it's got one of the
most mineral-rich areas for rubies and
emeralds in in the entire country and
who's harvesting it china why don't we
invade alaska
with music it's kind of the joke we have
you know when we have jack bosovich here
or like daniel turner they're both like
invade alaska i mean there's tremendous
resources there why don't we do it why
don't we why don't we use our own
resources this is the funniest part we
always talk about you know the left
again the left always talks about
climate and environmental you know
things like this but we're one of the
most environmentally friendly like
nations that you can think of i mean we
are exceptionally responsible with our
harvesting principles we are
exceptionally responsible i mean look
one of the best examples i have people
in florida were attacking the u.s sugar
and some of these companies saying that
they were actually destroying the
waterways they weren't talking about
runoffs and spill offs like that they
pointed it to the fingers of agriculture
what they didn't look at is that this
same company
over generates through their refineries
25 000 kilowatts and gives it back to
the actual people but so so we're one of
the most responsible but yet we'll go
and buy an import from china russia and
all the others who have the least
responsible way
harvesting and then we're okay with that
again it's like your food analogy right
it's like why would you kill that animal
why don't you just go to the store where
you know no animals were harmed exactly
i mean that's that's exactly what we're
looking at great man we want to prevent
ourselves and america from being able to
do things which we do more responsibly
but we're going to turn a blind house
abroad it's a big trick it's hypocrisy
so a lot of people complained about
trump the trump administration removing
environmental protections for companies
and then it realized was that was
because it was bringing companies it was
the only way to bring companies back to
the united states so pros and cons i
mean you can say it's a bad thing by all
means you're free to say so i'm not
saying it's a good thing that's why he
did it
when we say to a company you've got to
spend more on your minimum wage when we
say we're going to raise your taxes
when we say we're going to regulate you
to make it impossible for you to work
and then we say but any product you make
overseas can enter this country with no
taxes what do you think those companies
are going to do and by the way i'm going
to be like china i would completely
abolish the epa
let me let me just tell you as a
business owner they literally were i
wanted to create a a training facility
for one of the law enforcement
departments right and they were they had
someone who came out and did an
environmental study to make sure that
there was no ferns or any type of like
protected thing out there right so they
said oh no no you can't build here and
then all of a sudden out of the blue
they were like unless you paid the 60
000
environmental credit
and then we'll allow you to do it i mean
look it's the biggest scheme in the
world i mean i had to actually ask the
epa for permission to build on my land
that i owned that i was donating back to
the law enforcement department to be
able to train on and then had to pay a
60 000 credit and in the meantime
glyphosate there's there's studies and
evidence that it's causing cancer and
farmers and but monsanto somehow is now
using it okay
it's it's a it's an herbicide or it's a
fungicide and it kills bugs basically so
they're spraying all these crops with
this roundup now they're using it as a
desiccant meaning before the vegetables
are ready to be harvested they're not
dry so they spray it with roundup to dry
them out and then they harvest it talk
about unethical org practices
agriculture practices we have this
wonderful organic system you've got to
pay massive amounts of money to get your
stuff registered through and then
they're they're desiccating our crops
with
toxin i've i've heard these stories you
know like you were mentioning about uh
the fee and everything i was watching a
video
where uh a guy apparently was was
working on his own land and then one day
someone shows up and said you have to
stop the development of you know your
property because we saw a bird
they said you know i've even had them
have to come you had to pay money to
destroy
and properly return the land back to
what it was prior to your building wow
because they saw a certain kind of
tortoise in the area or
in in florida for example not only do
you have to go through the epa
roundabout but then they have to do an
ancestral study to make sure that there
was no native americans who had at one
point i mean they find a an arrowhead or
something they're like oh no no this was
an ancestral land therefore you can't
build yeah but like everything is
agreed so it's either either
you know either there's there's uh
reasonable development
or there's no or there's or there's none
i think reasonable development of any
land includes real environmental
protections obviously like we don't want
you dumping waste in the rivers and
things like that when you're building a
septic system you'll need like the you
know um you need the pits etc what is it
called what's the field the leech field
you'll need a leech field and all that
stuff you know you got to make sure it's
not running off on someone's property
but when they can abuse their power the
government does and they are the um
you got the uh what are they called
neo-nicotinide pesticides which are now
there's evidence that it's disrupting
the the bees are like getting it in
their system and then they can't find
their way and then they die off and they
think that's causing colony collapse
disorder it's really irresponsible for
the environmental protection agency to
be giving monsanto this kind of power
which is now bayer bear purchased
monsanto because they wanted to get rid
of the bad press from the name
that sounds like a 20 to me thank you
well this is what people fail to realize
whenever you have these large government
agencies coming around to regulate any
sector of the economy they just end up
in the pocket of the highest bidder so
of course monsanto is going to get away
with everything they're doing and then
for some reason when you criticize the
big corporations that are ripping us off
and the government that's selling us out
to them you're the fascist no no now
you're a domestic terrorist oh yeah
remember i mean
they up the ante on this now i mean even
poor parents who are just wanting a
balanced curriculum in their
neighborhoods or domestic terrorists i
mean this this has been that's great
something that they're just throwing out
and this is this is why though i think
virginia turned red and i believe this
because kitchen table issues you know
parents have a right you know i'm a
father so i've got two boys 17 and seven
and so i can tell you right now do i
care about my child's curriculum you're
damn right i do and these teachers
unions are running like the epa or any
other big government and they're just
saying well it's our way or the highway
and if you oppose it
well you're a domestic terrorist yeah
that's what i like is when you oppose
the government and then all of a sudden
you're considered evil because you
oppose or you're put on a watch list
yeah a government it's a fascist
government well let's yeah let me pull
up this uh this next story now that
we're kind of getting into the thick of
things here we got the story from
newsweek
targeted assassinations coming if civil
war breaks out adam kinzinger adam
kinzinger has uh spoken on this issue he
spoke with i think cnn and the view
and he said that there's a real
possibility of civil war in this country
and it's coming from a guy who is
i wouldn't even call him a republican at
this point but it's kind of weird
because what left and right don't mean
anything anymore whether you're a
democrat or republican is also mostly
meaningless because you could be an
establishment uniparty republican you
could be a progressive democrat or a
corporate democrat
this is just a guy who hates trump
he made a very very good point though he
said people are separating into tribes
people don't live in the same realities
anymore and he believes that if there is
a civil war it's going to be targeted
assassinations that's that's going to be
the level of conflict we see i certainly
hope not but for all the people who you
know even to this day still these
establishment leftists want to mock me
saying that i'm crazy for bringing up
this idea of civil war it's really funny
now when i'm you know trolling on on
twitter and i see them posting like you
know i used to make fun of him because
he wouldn't stop talking about civil war
but now the guardian and newsweek and
and even the new york times are talking
about it so like i don't know man maybe
something's happening it's like yeah
maybe i wasn't wrong to say i feel like
we're heading in this direction when
you've got
people that are choosing their politics
based on whether they hate you or not
like the alec baldwin thing or the
freedom convoy the workers of the world
are uniting and the left opposes it yo
this makes literally no sense the people
who literally say that they are for the
blue collar is exactly the ones who are
trying to constantly attack the blue
collar it's it's it's it's backwards and
look under president trump the one thing
i've talked about and i talked about
this with congressman jim jordan you
know the republicans were looked at as
kind of the wine and cheese party for
the longest time right
what president trump did was he brought
it back to where the republican party is
about the beer and blue jeans party yeah
we are the party of the american worker
we are the party of the blue-collar
worker and that's what i love to be a
part of that changed so fast in my
lifetime that the republicans became the
blue card party party blue collar party
well you know you know why democrats are
white collar what the heck the
republicans and the democrats were both
corporate shills the democrats feigned
supporting the working class when donald
trump stormed the gates
the establishment uh republicans fled
the lincoln project they're democrats
now i mean they claim they're they're
principled republicans but once they've
accomplished their mission we're going
to make sure trump doesn't get
re-elected they come out and go
donate to us anyway because republicans
are bad
or to our sex scandals that went on in
lincoln
let's ignore those let's ignore those
right but i'm you know you know with
what uh kenzinger is saying we also have
another article from the guardian that
where they said we're in the civil war
it's here we've had the new york times
saying it ray dalio a billionaire has
come out and said it again yesterday
that if you look at legislation in this
country republicans
are being accused of voter suppression
democrats are being accused of stripping
voter security neither side agrees the
other side is working you know honestly
and legitimately i don't think it
matters if who's right you know you
sitting at home you think well i know
which side is right you know we're right
i'm right that's not relevant to the
point the point is if neither side
agrees
they both think they are right doesn't
matter it's kind of like fighting is
going to stop democrats are looking at
the ship and the captain is in the
ship's
ship and it's sailing but the captain
was psychopathic it was donald trump and
we can't have a psychopath piloting the
ship the republicans are looking at the
democrats is the ship is shooting
explosives in every direction and
killing everything around it but so it
doesn't they're not less it's less about
the captain to them it's but it's no no
i i i i think that we're at the
political civil war i i don't think and
it's it's spiraling out towards the
american people so what's happening is
is that you know president trump came in
and he kind of unveiled that there was
corruption and all this on both sides
and he wouldn't be part of the swamp he
wouldn't be part of the establishment
because one he can't be bought and he
didn't need it but the thing that we're
we're seeing right now is where people
have woken up
and and it's it's now where we have
identified even more strongly the
two-party system and we're on opposing
pendulums you know it's now swing
extreme left swing extreme right and the
people are reacting to that but you know
here's the issue and to address what you
said in as well it's not going extreme
right it's going center right far left
center right far left
if you look at pugh's research on this
from 1994 there's a there's a scale from
zero to ten zero being far left ten
being far right in 1994 the democrats
were a five they were centrists and the
republicans were a six center-right
in 2004 the democrats moved over i think
to a four jumping one point to the left
and republicans jumped about a point to
the left to a five
republicans are at a 6.5 right now
they're a half point more right wing
more conservative than they were in 1994
but democrats jumped from five to a two
meaning they're three points further
left the jump is absolutely on the left
no no no argument that they're the most
radical zero argument on that i mean and
and the the problem is that we have to
try and balance the scale as cons i tell
you all the time like look it's like
this glass right so i'm a conservative
the republican party is nothing more
than a repository for the the
conservative ideals that i have the
problem is that we have too many
republicans like adam kinzinger who
claims to be a republican who are not
willing to protect and not willing to
actually help to conserve
those values that are actually in there
that makes us republicans that's that's
the difference or americans or americans
what's the what the january that's what
it is it's americans versus americans
now that's what it comes down to it
really is and um i think it's funny
because it's the old trope of uh glenn
beck or hannity you know they hate
america and i'm like well they really do
and they all right i don't know i don't
want to fall into that no they do bro
bro i don't think there's a they man i
think we all want different we all love
america and want it to be different
technically you're right there's no they
in that when we refer to the left it's
an it's a very very large group of
different political factions with shared
common interests but it's it's it's not
completely unified corporate democrats
obviously don't want communism the
communists don't like the corporate
democrats but they unify around certain
issues the same is true for republicans
center right traditional conservatives
religious folk you've got the
post-liberals who are now finding
themselves with republicans and that's a
pro-choice pro-life disagreement but the
issue i really do think comes down to a
few fundamental issues do you like this
country or not do you think this country
is inherently evil or not do you believe
in the constitution
are you authoritarian or libertarian
there is a they when we say that i'm
referring to people who outright don't
like the constitution so
constitutionalists and i don't like to
say
that because of the co-dependency
dependency
left and right are two words that mean
basically tribe one tribe two yeah call
it tribe a and b you know how about this
it's true you know we don't want anyone
to be lesser so we'll say tribe one and
tribe a
nice everybody can be you know whatever
but when i look at adam kinzinger and he
comes out and he says there's going to
be targeted assassinations you know the
the right has lost their mind or
whatever i'm like bro you're the one on
the january 6 committee issuing these
subpoenas and trying to put the former
administration in prison yeah you that
and i'm not talking about the the the
investigation i'm talking about filing
subpoenas against former staff members
and threatening them with prison because
they refuse to comply
with what what the other side views is
unconstitutional well let me just let me
just ask this question though you know
he's acting like this is something new
are we not calling the incident that
involved uh representative steve scalise
a targeted assassination yeah i mean we
had a left winger who came out bernie
sanders guy and literally shot
and nearly killed steve scalise almost
so killed a bunch of people that's
that's right i mean so my point is is
that you know he can't say that it's
just now what it was for me for me this
is adam kenzinger just trying to stay
relevant for me this is adam kenzinger
trying to position his next job next to
whoopi goldberg or on the cnn he may be
late to the party but he's not wrong
when when rand paul got attacked
he lost a piece of his lungs they
celebrate it to this day they thought it
was hilarious not every single democrat
no but but a lot of them when donald
trump was attacked at the white house
and they tore the barricades down set
fire to a guard post and torched the
church and trump was ushered into the
emergency uh bunker they laughed at him
in the corporate press the problem with
they were gonna talk about insurrection
attacking the white house and breaking
down the barriers and assaulting federal
agents i think that was possible
threatening the civil rights united
states yeah and exactly to this day they
laughed that they did it right so so
when they come out and they cry oh it's
an insurrection i'm like yo i literally
don't care what you think y'all are
celebrating you know i'll say this your
boos need
your booze mean nothing i've seen what
makes you cheer never a more apt
statement i know it's a joke from rick
and morty but it's completely applicable
these people cheer when they try to burn
down a church in front of the white
house and try to breach the barricades
and injure federal federal officers set
fire to a guard post and then they boo
when right wingers riot at the capitol
yo i don't care about who's writer who's
wrong the fact is both sides
are engaged in an escalation of
hyperpolarization
and i think
there i i don't see any way this this
this comes back together it's sort of i
think that we need to create the
children we need to teach start teaching
the kids now because what what's gonna
happen is they're gonna laugh at other
people's trauma violence and like see
someone else get hurt a political rival
and they'll laugh and then kids will see
that and as they grow up these people
don't realize they're laughing at their
political rivals getting hurt but if if
kids see that and then decide they don't
like you and you were the one that was
hurting that laughing at that otherwise
they're going to start doing that to you
and laughing at you it's going to become
a cycle it's already happened there have
been kids who have been brutally beaten
for not wearing masks we need to help
the kids we really need to seize control
of the narrative and communicate to
these children well this is the thing
it's not just about the radical left
that's a huge part of it and there's
absolutely no doubt that the left is far
more radical than the right is currently
it's but it's also a question of how
insane the center has gotten in what is
just considered normal moderate politics
the fact that for the past two years
children have been forced to wear masks
in school and anyone who's spoken out
against that or said i'm not going to
cover my face has been perceived as if
there's some kind of maniac who wants to
go around spreading viruses and killing
people um
even though and i know we can't get into
some of the details on the the cdc here
but
the problem is
the center has gotten so crazy
and when you look at where they're at
now you start to peer into the past and
realize things have been far outside of
anything even remotely reasonable for a
very long time for example well
it's partisan but when you look at the
things that democrats and republicans
are willing to come together and agree
on they're all really terrifying too
it's the reasonable center that tells us
that we have to go to these wars in the
middle east that cost trillions of
dollars it's the reasonable center that
told us that we need to spend all of the
money and raise the debt ceiling and now
we're 30 trillion dollars in debt i
don't think so i don't think so you
don't think it's the reason i don't
think it's all right these are the
bipartisan things that the left and
right i agree with him on this i don't
think it's a reasonable center at all
well i'm using i'm using it's reasonable
here no no
nancy pelosi and rachel maddow that you
know sure the people advocating for war
are not reasonable centrists they're
corporatists democratic uniparty
whatever no yeah no exactly i mean my
point is like that represents the
position of the status quo that's not
some radical position that's outside of
the system and that's what i'm saying
when i'm referring to the radical center
i'm saying these are the things that the
left and right agree upon and the things
that they have in common are actually in
many cases way more insane than the
things that separate them
i'll tell you what's very interesting to
me though and i i i posted an article
recently about this you know when
president trump came into office
everyone argued that he was going to
launch the next world war three yep you
know and this is a guy who literally
could not have gotten us to a safer
position i mean created the abraham's
accord sort of creating an arab
coalition to be able to fight their own
wars so we don't have to be
interventionist started looking at
drawdown so that we could get out of you
know afghanistan and iraq and all these
other areas and start focusing on the
america first agenda meanwhile the thing
about is the democrats are actually
saying this now where are we right now
we're literally deploying troops to be
able to go into ukraine and other areas
to fight against russia creating the
cold war or the 1920s all over again and
these are the exact people who are
pointing fingers at the republican party
yeah
when they were complaining about him
potentially starting a civil war they
were just upset that they weren't going
to get to do it first if you ever did
well good thing for them they actually
were responsible for a lot of it yeah
i feel like uh exactly the night is
always dark before the dawn man i'm
hoping so i've been listening to dave
smith he went in rogan a couple days ago
i was talking about the war in yemen and
about the united states relations with
saudi arabia and like saudis like saud
is like one of the most gruesome regimes
in the world you know it's a
dictatorship kingdom
and they treat people they're women
horribly and yada yada goes on and on
but they're just bombing farms in yemen
and fishing boats and murdering people
murdering generations of humans
and the u.s is selling them weapons to
do it
maybe not to do it they're selling the
weapons
you're failing to understand though also
what the proxy militias from iran the
houthis are doing i mean they literally
shut down and attacked saudi aramco they
actually went in there they're launching
missiles last week they just launched
another missile it landed in the uae
that killed some of the people there so
i mean
the bottom line is that the people that
saudi are actually fighting against are
the iranian proxy militias that were
down in the gulf of aden and all those
other areas while i agree with you we
necessarily shouldn't be involved in
that war and that's a war between the
middle east and that region and for
their own stability and things like this
and i'm again i'm anti-interventionists
you know the idea being able to support
allies or supporting the others i mean
this is this is one of those areas where
it starts to become a quagmire how deep
do you get in but i'll tell you right
now though it's not like saudi was just
going out there and saying oh well
here's some random farmers we're going
to kill them no no these were actually
houthi rebels who had actually launched
attacks and who are actually killing
saudis and killing uh uae soldiers and
things like this over in the area and
are still launching missiles and rockets
into abu dhabi still today so you're
saying they're firing the missiles from
iran and then they're targeting yeah
they're actually firing them from yemen
and launching into other areas are we
sure they're not false flags oh we're
100 also so here's the thing so the
problem and i just want to mention this
you're absolutely correct that the
houthi rebels do a lot of horrible
things they have child soldiers but the
problem is whenever you look at any
conflict in the middle east you're going
to see a lot of evil on both sides and
there's truth in that with respect to to
any conflict you see even if you're
rooting for a particular side war crimes
are common unfortunately but i will say
this there is a blockade preventing food
from entering yemen and tens of
thousands of people are starving to
death civilians have been made the
target of the warfare here but that's
always the case you always have
collateral damage going back to your
point do you have proof well of course
you do look at the u.n security council
look back when you either had bon ki
moon who was the actual general
secretary or even gutierrez where they
actually caught the iranian ships who
are who are actually shipping in
mid-range ballistic missiles into the
houthis which is a violation of
resolution 2231 or the jcpoa so there is
factual like you know
proof where the iranians were actually
supporting the houthis to be able to
launch attacks against saudi arabia so
that's not anything that's even up for
debate when it's actually been caught by
international
so so this is a a good example you know
the story ian is is telling the talking
point about yemen
you got to be careful about your sources
and so i want to bring this back to a
domestic issue um that's really
difficult to talk about and this is a
story of amir lock
so we have this story from
progressive.org
someone sold a holding a sign saying
amir lock was lynched by mpd on two two
two two
twin cities protesters are mourning and
marching for a mere lock for those of
those that aren't familiar this is the
video of a no knock warrant body camera
footage
police enter an apartment
start yelling within nine seconds they
kick a couch a man sleeping under a
blanket with a gun
emerges holding the gun proper trigger
discipline and within a split second
he's shot and killed
now the challenge here is upon watching
the video upon hearing the official
story that's come out it sounds like the
police lied about what happened the
official report was that they entered
the home
the the person in question pointed a a
loaded gun
shots were fired and then he died to
make it sound like this guy amir
actually fired the cops
now we're hearing from the family he had
a lice a concealed carry permit for this
gun now we're seeing posts all over
reddit where they say why isn't every
second amendment advocate furious about
this where's the nra i mean this is a
legal gun owner sleeping on a couch a no
knock warrant he wasn't the subject of
the warrant and i'll tell you exactly
why
i don't believe you
now if this guy when i watched this
video my immediate reaction was this
looks like the cops were wrong this guy
was not targeted to the warrant he was
sleeping as his right with his gun
probably dumb but he's allowed to do it
he never pointed the gun at every
anybody within nine seconds they shot
and killed him just because he was
legally carrying a weapon
the problem is
left
you lie about everything over and over
again so now i see a video that should
have my blood boiling and i'm like well
for me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me you expect me to come out
and march alongside you over this issue
you expect people who defend gun rights
to believe you after every lie we've
already been through from the beginning
of black lives matter with trayvon
martin with what happened in ferguson
that i personally witnessed to to uh
ahmed arbory to uh george floyd every
single lie and the same lawyers like ben
crump are involved in this one so i'll
tell you this
i don't like it i watch the video looks
bad but i'm gonna wait i'm gonna wait
because you guys lie all the time
non-stop and i'm not falling for it ever
again
nice one dude thanks for bringing this
up i gotta say i think you pretty much
hit on all the topics on that one and
i'm like all right moving on well no i
mean i mean look here's the bottom line
does he have a right to be able to
possess the firearm absolutely because
i'm a supporter of constitutional carry
i believe that it's not something that
should be provided to us by governmental
rights it was already put into the
constitution and i'll go a step further
and say it's an it's an inalienable
right for us to be able to have defense
however i gotta say as a person who has
been deployed multiple times who has
served overseas i can't say outside of
i've always had my rifle within a arm's
length away from me or i've always had a
pistol which is you know in the hole
something like that i can't say that
it's not a bit odd that a gentleman
actually slept
with himself in trigger discipline under
the blanket and rose so again not
commenting on it does he have a right to
do it absolutely has a right to do it
let's see what the actual research in
the investigation finds exactly yeah um
you know my thoughts on this along with
many other instances if you're an
american citizen i don't care about your
race you have a right to keep and bear
arms i love it i'm simultaneously you
know getting criticism uh over these
more so the gun rights thing because i
said every american has a right to own
nuclear weapons under the second
amendment because it says nucle it says
arms keep and bear arms nuclear arms or
weapons i went on to then say that we
should prob you know it would probably
very easily easy to amend that most
people probably want that change and i'm
not advocating for uh people to have
nuclear weapons but of course far be it
from the lying establishment media and
left-wing activists to be honest about
what my opinion was
so
how are you going to criticize me
that i that people you know
they're saying that i i would not
support gun rights for minorities when
you're also simultaneously criticizing
me for saying people should be allowed
to have nuclear weapons no the issue is
this guy is allowed to have his gun he's
allowed to sleep he's allowed to sleep
with his gun and he's allowed to hold
his gun in his own home and i got to
tell you this when it came to brandon
taylor's boyfriend and they kicked his
doran that was found to be a lawful
shooting when brentel's boyfriend opened
fire on the cops if you kick someone's
door in and they're not aware of what's
going on in the open fire that was found
to be justified self-defense from a
legal gun owner so for this guy to be
killed within nine seconds of an unknock
warrant i think it's really really
really awful but i also think i'm
probably being lied to and so the last
thing i'm gonna do is in any way support
people who lied before lied again lied
again and in all honesty probably lying
now you cried wolf too much and i'm not
interested in hearing it anymore sorry
did they say that he pointed the gun how
did they phrase that i can't remember
exactly what the cops said but they said
something like he was an unarmed man was
was seen shots were fired and then he
died because he did point the gun at the
ground he didn't point it anyway he
pointed it at the ground no he didn't i
thought he got up and held it proper
he's just holding it forward okay when
they started shooting him it's like he's
laying on a couch and he sets up trouble
for sure and he's sleeping with his gun
he's probably expecting something just
in case something bad someone comes in
or
that's not relevant
it's not relevant exactly and to be
completely fair if you're living in some
of these cities like new york for
example where criminality has just gone
through the roof or chicago or any of
the rest and you live in kind of you
know a less affluent area and you feel
that crime is is a potential threat that
could happen to you at any moment
hey why wouldn't you have the right to
defend yourself look i'm one of those
however again i'm like you i don't want
to catch myself into this where we don't
know the facts we don't know the reason
for entering we don't know the guy's
background we don't know whether or not
the a surveillance team had watched him
enter that building just a moment ago
and maybe he had committed something
earlier again i don't want to speculate
when there's actual continuing
investigations on things but the one
thing that is without debate
is that under the second amendment right
everyone has a right to bear arms and so
here's the issue i remember when the
george floyd thing happened and i made
like five or six videos where i was like
this is appalling this is a problem we
have with policing they shouldn't have
done this then the body camera footage
comes out and i was like boy was i wrong
the dude's fighting the dude's on drugs
the dude says put me on the ground
several times and then i'm like yeah i
think the cops did bad but the initial
reaction was i thought these cops killed
this guy now it's manslaughter now it's
like okay they should not have done this
of course we got you know murder
conviction out of that
then the almond arbory thing i mean that
is a glorious piece of deceit deception
misinformation that ahmed arbory was
jogging in that neighborhood is one of
the most laughable lies i've ever heard
he wasn't
and i don't even learn this
until we had on a couple lawyers who had
been following the case and they said no
the prosecution even said he was a
burglary suspect that's not in dispute i
was like wait a minute what that's not
in dispute the prosecution even
acknowledged that yes i was like wow
boy they lied to me that's all they do
he was jogging in work boots through a
construction site 20 miles from where he
lives yeah
but again though this is this this is
where identity politics works for the
left so that lie was going to be spun in
a way that was going to benefit them in
some way i mean it's the same thing that
right now just commenting on you know
again identity politics for the left has
become their bread and butter i just
hope that the right doesn't get caught
in this idea of like trying to like
follow suit the reason i brought this up
following the yemen point is that we
hear a lot this talking point about the
crisis in yemen and i'm at the point
where i'm just like yo
unless i read it and research it and
know what's going on i just don't
believe it anymore hearing it from dave
smith is not proof positive well i did
hear this so no to be fair i did a bit
of research on yemen for an educational
cartoon we were creating about it and it
is really horrible i mean there are some
estimates from um data that's been
extrapolated from unicef and different
historic studies they've done on
malnourishment in the region that says
as many as 85 000 children may have
starved to death become because of this
and actually that's like the midpoint
they said it was between
60 000 and 110 000 based on their
estimates well and bear in mind that
that there was already issues with yemen
i mean they were already at a risk of
running out of natural like fresh water
to begin with that was already a problem
but from a you know looking at it from
someone who was literally looking at
terrorism counterterrorism for the
longest time in the middle east and was
a analyst for over 10 years and looking
at these areas i can tell you if you
looked at the aqap
where the al qaeda arabian peninsula and
where the gulf of aden in those areas
started spiraling out of control
under the obama administration the obama
administration it was a small contained
pocket in aqfp he started launching a
drone structure and they started growing
growing growing growing and then iran
got involved started adopting all the
houthis and started getting these riled
up and then you started utilizing again
it's like you and i right if we got in a
fight i don't want to fight in my house
i don't want to fight in your house
because we're going to destroy something
let's go fight in his house
that's what iran that's what iran and
saudi arabia continue obama wanted the
instability absolutely we wanted syria
to fall so we could build our pipeline
there's also a good argument to be made
that he wanted to placate uh the saudis
because of the nuclear deal that was
done with iran it's all very complicated
but i will say this it's true that yemen
was if i'm not mistaken the poorest
country in the middle east before this
began but that said placing a blockade
around them when they were already
having trouble getting water i don't
want to be absolutely egregious i don't
want to
completely divert into talk about yemen
i was just bringing up the fact that you
know we've heard that a lot and i'm at
this point in my life where i'm just
like
if an activist comes to me an activist
and says something about some place i'm
gonna be like dude you're an activist
i'm not gonna believe the reason i
brought up yemen is because we were
talking about making concessions to your
military it was kind of the conversation
about maybe your military opponents
because like you want that we want this
we don't really agree but we're going to
like look the other way for you you look
the other way it's a marriage of
convenience yeah we got saudi selling
our oil and u.s dollars around the world
guaranteeing that our us dollar still
has some value basically so they're like
our front but that's that's right
and if we betray them they're going to
stop the issue is again
not to get us into a talk about
how horrible the assads are what's going
on with yemen
what i'm trying to talk about is how the
media has lied and manipulated us into
foreign wars how the media has lied and
manipulated people into rioting and
burning down their own cities and how
they're continuing to do it and we have
the potential for a very real riot right
now i'm already hearing scuttlebutt that
there's potential riots this weekend
over what happened with amir loch it's
starting to get warm out it was 65
degrees out here today
when it's warm people riot when there's
conflict there's there's riots but let
me let me let me pull this up right here
i have this poll from civics i love
showing
black lives matter
opposition support
general sentiment
people may start rioting this weekend
over amir lock being shot and killed by
police and you know what
i don't want people to get hurt i don't
want there to be riots i don't want
people to riot i don't want people to
get shot by cops but you know what
democrats establishment media
you if you do this you will face such a
reckoning man take a look at this
before this is this is among all voters
is this all voters those independent
voters sorry
before george floyd died support for
black lives matter among independent
voters was at 41 and opposition was 28.
after george floyd died 51 of
independent voters
supported black lives matter then the
riots happened and the support started
to completely crash then jacob blake got
shot
after the derek chauvin trial black
lives matter support dropped
dramatically and opposition rose
dramatically
right before check us out right before
the ahmed arboring uh ahmed arbury
verdict opposition was going down and
support was going up and then right
after the verdict opposition went up
so these people want to come out and
they say oh armored armory and these
people he was jogging they lynched him
why do independent voters now oppose you
more
following that verdict
because people were lied to correct
that no that's the guy who was going to
go it's because people were lied to i
mean look and at the end of the day
no one yes is if you find something
that's wrong sure let's go ahead we're a
nation of laws i think that the
lawlessness that the left basically
promotes with these quote unquote
protests which are actual riots no one
can get behind that and that loses
support and especially whenever there's
some type of a you know a jury that you
know sees the case and actually renders
a verdict on it
they feel that justice has been rendered
and so the continuation of lawlessness
doesn't actually
increase the awareness to your cause it
actually denigrates it because it's just
lawlessness justifying lawlessness if
democrats want to preserve whatever
votes they might get they need to come
out right now and say do not protest
do not i mean like president trump when
he said
go home peacefully
but yet somehow that was inciting
violence dude trump was up against the
military-industrial complex he had a
challenge these guys are on the side of
that thing and they're trying to
manipulate the voters only trump is
trying to manipulate everybody and not
not in a mean or cruel they're just
manipulating trump was trying to be the
voice of the people and people didn't
like it because they thought that how
can a billionaire be
the voice of the people but the reality
was that's exactly what he was trying to
do he was trying to build the middle
class he was trying to hold our
adversaries accountable he was trying to
stop our trade imbalances because i mean
the guy is the art of negotiation and he
became from the art of negotiation to
the art of peace deals i mean you look
at the abraham's accord look at all the
different things that he was doing so
again this is i mean he did more in four
years than most do an eight it's
remarkable how
donald trump gets gets attacked for that
by the establishment left once again
they're like well these deals are
actually bad it's like you know what man
it is we we are we are truly living in a
period of of of psychosis
but let me just stress
i love civics because you can see that
independent voters this is brilliant by
the way the oh yeah they tend to reflect
republicans
so when we talk about
which side is truly right well
independent voters and republicans agree
with each other for the most part i
think it's fair to say at the very least
the majority of people disagree with the
establishment democrat world view and i
think it's fair to say based on
simple research like they lied about all
these things hands up don't shoot
talk about a lie
you know that story ian
michael brown had his hands up and that
the darren wilson i think was the name
of the cop was that cup shot and killed
him and then started marching around the
hands up hands up don't shoot and then
the obama's report comes out showing he
didn't have his hands up in fact
department he rushed the cop and he
reached for his gun he literally
committed suicide are we talking about
the same eric holder who is responsible
for fast and furious which is actually
putting weapons to the hands of cartels
that are being utilized against our cbp
today so if the if the democrat voter
wants to believe those lies and live in
wally world by all means go ahead and do
so but if they want to get violent and
and start fighting as they've been doing
we've got a very serious problem yeah it
was not a right-wing trump supporter who
uh went into portland and shot and
killed a bernie supporters the other way
around that's right it was a black lives
matter supporter with a tattoo on his
neck who shot and killed the trump
supporters walking down the street well
i mean think about it look at the you
know antifa.com website where does it
actually take you to well during the
campaign when you would type in tv.com
it would actually take you over to one
location but my point is though we know
who the intolerant actually support and
they support democrats more than they
support the conservatives i mean we've
seen that time and time against the
liberal economic political no to be fair
antifa.com was likely bought purchased
by someone on the right i thought you
redirected it too what was it joe biden
well it was it was done by joe it was it
was supporting biden harris and now it
actually auto links to the
whitehouse.gov corey when you're in the
military what was it like knowing that
we're part of this liberal economic
order and the military industrial
complex is out there and like but it's
still important i understand like the
value of the us military we really can
make the world a better place we can
preserve a lot of goodness but what was
it like psychologically well i got to be
honest with you when you're serving in
the military i'm not thinking about the
industrial complex i'm not thinking
about gd lockheed martin or the other
you know we're going through these
military trainings and we're sitting
here looking at cohesiveness we're
looking at our brothers to the left and
right of us you're not thinking about
any of these things you're only thinking
about keeping one another safe you're
only thinking about the fact that you
know again i tell people this all the
time it's not the boots it's the suits
you know whenever something goes wrong
and these boards are being volunteered
and you know voted on it's not us who
are sitting in the military who are
actually voting on these things we're
just out there to basically follow
orders and be able to try and go ahead
and do what we thought is the right
thing which to provide protection for
our constitutional liberties and
freedoms or to help to free the
oppressed you know the old special
forces deopresso lieber mentality so as
someone who was in the military i wasn't
thinking about the industrial complex i
wasn't thinking about these generals
looking at their million dollar boards
after they get done retiring i was
thinking about making sure that my guys
who were in my team were going to be
safe on the ground that was it people
complain about just following orders but
it's like can you even have a military
if people don't just follow orders well
well look so here's the thing i'm
i'm one of those people that if you tell
me go out and kill these children and
you know we're just telling you to do it
so you should do it no i'm not going to
do that i mean it's not blindly
following orders it's looking at the
facts so
let's just say as an example regardless
of the reasoning for the iraq war you
know regardless of the falsified
documentation or the anthrax or the wmd
whatever the case may be we did know for
a fact that saddam ran in a tyrannical
rule we did know that there was shia
that were being just slaughtered you
know at random we did see the halabja
incident with the kurds we did see so
it's like you know you're still
eliminating a bad guy right the problem
with america is is that not that we're
you know going in and eliminating
terrorists or bad guys the problem was
that we thought that we could actually
create
democracy this nation building thing is
the biggest quagmire that the bush
administration ever put us into and it
was the biggest mistake and that was to
prop up the industrial complex let me
ask you about these uh the police we've
been seeing as of recent with what's
going on in the convoys the you know the
cops harassing that 78 year old men but
also the black lives matter protests
you've obviously got the left they've
been screaming abolish the police for
the past two years for really stupid
reasons but uh after a while i started
saying the same thing
because not only did we see um
obviously within the riots they weren't
uh shutting them down they weren't
prosecuting they weren't arresting uh
sometimes they were but for the most
part the justice system was not going
after these people they were getting a
free pass they got they got a free pass
in january 17th 2020 january 6 these
people get rotten solitary but when we
saw the police shut down small
businesses when we saw the police defend
black lives matter murals that were
painted illegally with seizure of
taxpayer money at that point i'm just
like you know maybe they're right
maybe maybe they've shoved it in our
face that the police will will
aid and abet the theft of taxpayer funds
for political messaging the police will
shut down private businesses and
violation the constitution
why would these cops just follow these
orders even though they're not only
unconstitutional but many ways illegal
outright and and why would i even bother
supporting them at this point well a lot
of them and i think we were talking
about this earlier actually we were
talking about the fact that a lot of the
really good ones they did leave they end
up going somewhere else and but but
you're only seeing this issue in
democrat controlled cities where you
already have a corrupt mayor because
remember it's not the law enforcement
that's usually the ones who are the
issue they are law enforcement they are
not legislators who are actually
creating these laws or creating these
types of of regulations and things that
they're trying to enforce but the
problem is that then the people who
oppose it
they just leave the cities and they go
to another place and they go hey look i
know that this mayor is trying to impose
something which is you know against
something i'm willing to to adhere to
and those cities just crumble from that
point yeah but you know when i see your
point don't get me wrong yeah let me
i'll tell you the story i tell everybody
it was when i was buying my first gun
uh i live i was in new jersey at the
time it's very difficult to get a gun it
took several months took like six months
actually because they were lying to me
about how to do it should it went to the
gun shop in the first place but there
was a woman should have been a florida
resident should have been a florida
resident in the first place uh well west
virginia we got constitutional carry so
this woman from pennsylvania uh where
you're allowed to have guns was going to
atlantic city she wanted to go gamble
she was like an older middle-aged woman
maybe in her 50s and
she crossed the bridge she gets pulled
over for like a tail light or something
and then when the cop walks up her
thinking i'll be responsible like i was
told politely informs the officer that
she she does have her her concealed
carry with her just so that he knows and
he said okay you know step out of the
vehicle ma'am uh put your hands behind
your back and she's shocked what's
happening because you're under arrest a
felony possession you're not allowed to
carry a gun in new jersey
why did that officer do that why didn't
that officer just say ma'am
it's five minutes back to philadelphia
you're gonna turn around i'm gonna
escort you to the bridge do not bring a
gun into new jersey it's a crime instead
he was like i think this woman should go
to prison for four years yeah that
sounds about right to me this is a
regular cop he's not dealing with a
right he's not stressed out he just
decided upon himself yeah maybe this is
an egregious
unconstitutional law
but
far be it from me i'd rather this woman
go to prison for four years than
totally with you i mean let's let's just
play devil's advocate for a minute
though let's let's say that this young
officer who probably hadn't been on the
academy very long let's just go ahead
and throw that out he's looking at it
going all right so i've got body cam my
supervisor's going to look at this and i
have an option to either enforce the law
because he was in the right of enforcing
the law or if i don't and i do the right
thing which is probably to say hey you
know what let's turn you back i'm going
to lose my job which means i can't feed
my family which means my kids look
they're i mean we have to look at all
the things i mean these law enforcement
officers first off a lot of them are on
35 000 a year 40 000 a year to risk
their lives
i mean i i understand your point but so
does it have to say that but does it
change if that's instead of it being a
60 or 7 year old does it change if it's
a 20 year old does it change if it's a
19 year old does it change as far as i
mean that's my point there's no
justification for someone this is why
constitutional carry needs to be across
all 50 states this is a constitutional
right to bear agreement i agree this
shouldn't even be in discussion the
issue here is a cultural problem
that you would have someone fresh out of
the academy be like i would rather this
woman go to prison for four years than
me lose my job
i mean that to me is evil but we don't
live in a society of
us or them i mean that's exactly what
the good for thee not for me you know
socialist leftist mentality is isn't it
the two-tiered justice system they can
get away with it but we can't well i
mean in chicago a great example is
politicians can carry guns and have
armed security but you can't new
jersey's the same way in fact in new
jersey
uh so i i talked to the police and i
said you know how do you get concealed
carry the only way that you can have a
gun on your person walking around in any
new jersey neighborhood as if you have a
concealed carry permit but new jersey is
actually a no issue state
it's not a real legal distinction it's
just everybody knows new jersey will not
give you one no matter what you do or
say
unless
you are worth a certain amount of money
or you have a certain amount of fame
well then or you know certain people who
will sign off like the share for like
exactly yeah i think it goes beyond the
sheriff i think in order to get signed
off on it it's like state level or
something ridiculous and they just throw
in the garbage basically and there's
laws about it because it is
unconstitutional but they'll no matter
what you do they'll just tell you to
shove off unless you can prove you you
work with a certain amount of money or
you're famous then they're like oh well
rich and or famous sir you are entitled
to a gun well because they're trying to
make the excuse that well i'm at more
risk and i have you know the ability for
people to try and attack me because of
my value because of my but again though
this is that two-tiered justice system
that i was just mentioning i mean look
good for the not for me i mean
this shouldn't even be a topic of
discussion tim that you you and i were
saying that before just go back to
constitutional carry and let's just get
over it i've had uh
situations in chicago stories from my
friends and things that i've experienced
one one story my friends told me is that
they were hanging out at the park and
they were smoking pot when they were
like teenagers
and uh uh a cop car pulls up and it
wasn't like a patrol car but it was very
obviously a police vehicle and uh my
friends freak out and they're like 16
and they throw their joint or whatever
and the cop laughs and he goes
dude we don't care that you're smoking
pot in the park we're looking for this
guy did you see him and they're like no
and he's like all right man later there
was other instances where the cops would
come by and see people with pipes and
stuff and then he would be like toss it
bro come on and the dude would like toss
it to the side and like you're good so
why is it that those cops in this
instance in chicago would be like i'm
not going to arrest some teenagers for
what's clearly illegal but another
circumstance like
a constitutional right
heavens you've got to go to prison for
that there are a lot of stories in
chicago of like a dad
who tried to get a gone to practice
family because the gun vines are so
insane lock them up go to prison well
too bad
you try to get them they deny you even
it's constitutional right you got no
criminal record whatever so they say
i'll drive to indiana 45 minutes pick
one up and then you go to prison for it
or or the states where they're like you
can have a gun in your car so long as
the ammo is not with it yeah
i mean i i don't know new jersey yeah i
don't understand maryland is apparently
maryland is that yeah maryland
i'll tell you what so so when i when i
first came to
the dc area and coming from florida this
was a massive shock for me
and it was the same thing i was talking
to someone about oh yeah you know i'm
going to take my you know pistol and
some ammo i'm going to go do some you
know shooting things like that at this
maryland gun range and they're like what
do you mean you're going to take your
ammo i was like well yeah i'm going to
save money because you know i used to
reload i used to do my own stuff so you
know i don't want to pay 10 a box back
then or 15 a box and they're like no no
each round that you bring is a felony
charge each round and i was like what
i mean this is just insane it's okay for
me to carry my gun but it wasn't okay so
i'm like so basically you're propping up
this gun shop because now i'm forced to
buy their ammo they can charge whatever
they want for it and i'm like
you also in order to buy uh weapons in
maryland it's particularly complicated
it's bad and the funny thing is west
virginia is just
20 30 minutes depending on where you are
or virginia in west virginia if you're a
resident you walk in you got to fill out
your next background check form yeah
then they send it to the feds takes a
few minutes and then you can buy your
time in florida you got to do a
background check but uh dc is shocking
to me because it's federal jurisdiction
and it's the most it's one of the most
strict jurisdictions in the country i
mean whether you like the guy or not or
enrique tario he had uh 30 round
magazines standard capacity magazines
and they arrested him for it unloaded
unloaded just pieces of plastic with
springs doesn't matter well and again i
love how people used to throw out this
term it's gun paraphernalia
i mean sticker of a gun on your shirt
exactly i mean how far do you go with
that
i think i think the issue is you know
i've said this before
if you don't like the fact that people
can have guns amend the constitution but
don't start violating the constitution
every single day because you're unhappy
with it it's it's crazy to me the
constitution is explicit i don't care
about what the reason is
a well-regulated mission militia being
necessary sure fine whatever the right
of the people to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed the reasoning is
is irrelevant yet what do we have
they've banned everything i love it when
they're like no one's coming to take
your guns and i'm just like waco
excuse me that was 30 years ago come on
o'rourke's exact comment right which
he's now
gone back on yeah but his exact comment
was is i am coming for your ar-15s what
an idiot i mean look and again if that's
not infringement
of my second amendment rights what is it
i honestly think that if you uh as in a
campaign declare your intent to violate
the constitution you should be
ineligible 100 that makes sense 100
agreed so when beto says i am going to
take your guns away it's like oh well
that's a direct statement in violation
of the constitution you can't be allowed
to hold power
would you let him run like the next
cycle then like if they if they atone
for the statement
you know it's it is an interesting point
because i'm a bit higher question bit
facetious but yeah how do you recover
from saying you intend to violate
people's rights because then was to
prevent you from once you're elected
from going back on that because you've
already shown your true intent but it
just wasn't popular and who knows if
you're lying all the time hey look well
that's just being a politician if you're
if you're a felon you can't own a gun
okay well if if you uh express publicly
public intent on a campaign trail to
violent constitution someone should be
able to file a lawsuit against you and
then it should go to the courts and the
courts would be like if for nor the
reason that he should know that he
violated the congress i'll tell you
what's even worse than that though what
about the felons who you're not allowed
to vote
i think felons should be allowed to vote
i mean that's absolutely absurd at the
end of the day if you go and you serve
and you atone for what what you've been
you know essentially prosecuted for
why shouldn't you maintain your
constitutional rights and liberties why
should you not still be able to vote in
our elections why should your voice not
count i want to stress the point for
those that
i'm literally referencing the madison
cawthran thing i know some left is going
to be like but tim said yesterday
they're trying to disqualify madison
cothran
yeah i'm saying you want to play ball we
can play ball if you want to claim that
madison hawthorne's speaking at a rally
it makes him ineligible then i'll come
right out and say you ever express
anything in violation of the
constitution then you're out i spoke at
a rally i spoke at a stop the steel
rally one time i mean should that ban me
in any way cause i was talking with alan
west and dana lash and we were just
talking about the fact that we really
want to just press for voter integrity
that's it that's a great we want to
secure our elections we should define it
i mean and going to that i laughed the
other day by the way and you'll all get
a kick out of this is the analogy i used
whenever they said that requiring voter
id is suppressing the elections
i almost asked them i said that's the
equivalent of a car manufacturer saying
that we should remove the brakes because
it suppresses the acceleration which it
does intentionally
i mean the whole point is safety in
there or you can say
it's a car dealership saying we've
removed all carfax you can't get it
anymore because it's a it's it threatens
the integrity of our industry dude you
got it this whole not having a life
trying to make sure you're not doing
wrong that's exactly right are they
gonna what is this and then they're
gonna be like okay if you really want
ids for voting okay you gotta sign up on
the blockchain and get your new perma id
that we can track you everywhere around
and you gotta take the chip with you
everywhere you go no here that's gonna
work well but think about it
getting an id
is difficult it's racist it's
suppressive
but let's look at vaccine passports
that that's not well so here's your
future here's your future in 20 years
some 16 year old is going to be going to
the dmv for his first license or
whatever he's going to finish driver's
debt in high school he's gonna walk in
he's gonna walk up and he's gonna be
like oh yeah i'm getting my driver's
license and they're gonna go okay do you
have uh your address i need two forms of
id and your vax card oh yeah i have it
right here oh uh your vax card is a
month out of date um
you haven't had your 15th booster well
it's out of date so you've got to do it
every month so you need to go to uh this
is a 7-eleven parking lot where you can
get updated and then come back okay and
the kid's going to leave and get
injected he's going to come back she's
going to go okay here you go now you
have your id and then they're going to
be like and do you want to register to
vote at the same time
then they're going to register him only
after he completes the process and has
his vax passport and all that stuff
you're going to have your mobile app on
your phone you can have your qr code
fortunately it looks like the way of the
vax stuff is on its way out the
canadiens man no that's the moon baby
it's the rat hope experiment i mean i do
have hope i'm not lying it's the rat
hope experiment you know the rat hope
experiment is
guy takes these cylinders full of water
puts a rat in it the rat swims for 15
minutes and then drowns he does it again
with other rats the rat swims for 15
minutes starts to drown he pulls it out
he dries it off lets it rest puts it
back in
the second time the rats would swim for
60 hours because they had hope that the
hand would pull them out if they just
held out a little longer i predicted
this
granted i've suggested the possibility
of many things so i'm not acting like
this is foresight i said because there
because a few months ago i did say i
thought the lockdowns were gonna get
worse because the democrats were
desperate i was wrong about that but i
also said i feared what would happen is
they would pull back
on the restrictions
to give everyone hope it's finally over
oh
and then several months later wham
double down i'll tell you what i knew
where this was heading whenever they
started issuing the vax cards and all of
a sudden you started seeing all of those
blank slots that are underneath it from
the very very beginning if it was really
about two and done and getting back to
society you'd have had two slots you'd
had it would have been done right when
you saw that there was six and seven and
eight extra slots underneath
you already knew this was pre-planned
that's why i called it the plan gimmick
not the pandemic dude donald rumsfeld
said when we go into iraq while we were
in afghanistan he actually said the
words when we go into iraq as if it had
been pre-planned this all this stuff is
they're just sitting back there like
what are we gonna do that's something
that's been pushed for for a very long
time though you have joe biden on record
saying he wanted to invade iraq back in
1997. it's all planned uh maybe not all
well maybe not it doesn't necessarily
have to be a plan it's just the fact
that that's what the establishment
always wanted they knew they'd be able
to rush themselves off of it
man this cove the weird it's so weird i
think um here's my prediction first yes
of course i know luke was right and i
was wrong luke said with omicron he
thinks everything's going to start
pulling back and that's basically what
we're seeing
but i think it's a good possibility that
uh october
all of a sudden it's like oh oh no it's
getting cold again and the cases are
skyrocketing we're gonna have to do
universal mail and voting again
everybody oh that that's guaranteed to
be utilized i mean look the bottom line
is is that
the lie has worked once they're going to
continue to utilize it until it's
basically pushed back upon and and
here's the other thing i'm not anti-vaxx
i think that if you feel that you have a
compromised immune function i think that
if you
want to protect yourself with other
areas i think that's your medical choice
your medical right to be able to do so
and that's why we created it but also on
the adverse if you don't want to take it
that's also your medical choice your
medical professor i mean this is why we
live in freedom we have freedoms and
liberties parental rights medical choice
i mean these are all things that we
that's serious i think it i i genuinely
mean it when i say just talk to a doctor
man we talked to our doctor we talked to
joe rogers uh joe rogan
joe rogan um dr rogan no uh i actually
posted that the other day i said i would
trust rogan over falchi well what what
joe rogan told us was he's like look man
don't like it was basically the gist of
it is don't just call a hospital like
find a doctor call them and see if
you'll get some help and then we found a
doctor who was like i want to give you
guys proper treatment and prescriptions
we have a plan and we got it and uh and
it was that simple and so i tell people
if you don't trust your doctor like i
don't know we found a doctor who is good
you you just got to shop you got to call
it two and three medical you know
opinions right that is
but also i don't think that we should
diminish the fact that our independent
immunity
is something that shouldn't be just
necessarily cast aside you can't just
say oh well your immunity oh don't worry
about that my personal belief it should
be focused on from the dawn of time are
we we have an immune system we have
white blood cells it's wonderful it's
it's what i've been talking about how if
one side of the culture war or the cold
civil war is for it the other side just
automatically opposes it you're right
and that's all it is trump was the one
who who warp speeded out this vaccine
and it was the left claiming they would
never go near it that's right then it
flipped because biden was in office and
biden wanted to push it out and all of a
sudden it's like
this is why i love that twitter handle
the defiant ls yes i mean that is so
fantastic because i see so many times
where he'll show some leftists going
would you trust this vaccine created
under trump and then like literally
after the bite administration comes in
they're like how dare you not get this
vaccine you know it's like that's why
it's clown world man and that's why i'm
just like i don't care to interact with
these people
it's just it's absurd
they're they're not
they sit there and claim everyone else
isn't acting in good faith but they
believe brian stelter is telling the
truth mr potato head it's it's
ridiculous that cnn can lie as often as
they do as overtly as they do and that's
why i genuinely believe any of these
lefties who come out and they're like
i believe this narrative i'm like you're
lying let me tell you how i personally
caught cnn and a lie so i don't know if
you guys know this or not but so
congressman ronnie jackson when the
failed afghan withdrawal occurred
had a family a mother and her three
children who were texas 13 natives who
were left behind in afghanistan and they
were literally you know being hunted
down by the taliban he called the dod
tried to get support couldn't do it
called the department of state tried to
get help couldn't do it called us
i ended up putting a team together that
that we'd assembled and whenever they
actually conducted the very first
successful overland rescue of americans
out of afghanistan and that was in
september
four hours
after we rescued him what do you think
the cnn headline was
state department saves four americans
cnn first one four hours after
it wasn't until i started to go on and
thank god there was platforms like sean
hannity who was allowing it uh who
you know literally just told the whole
story to his credit and i know this is
going to be a shocker however which is
probably why he's also not there but you
know who also gave me a fair shake
chris cuomo no why not he was the one
who said is it true
and we're going to bring on the person
that's going to tell the truth so going
back cnn was the first one to break that
lie
even after our team went through and you
look at ronnie jackson's post where he
says that it was three you know
life-threatening attempts to try and get
this family out of there and cnn and try
to give the state department full credit
of it how did you get them out of there
like classified stuff no the only reason
i won't talk a lot about the operational
steps because we're still like we just
got 12 people out uh about seven days
ago
and so i don't want to compromise our
operational security on that to where we
can try and look at the fact that we
want to try and continue to help and
save more um you know it's really a sad
thing when
a citizens but it's also a good thing
it's like these freedom truckers right
so it's good when citizens step forward
where the government fails i his
surrender to the taliban is one of the
most egregious losses in the united
states history it was not just a
surrender he not only surrendered to the
taliban but he gave china exactly what
they're asking for and what was even
more of what i think is a impeachable
crime here after not just leaving the
americans he funded okay we left 86
billion dollars in weapons armament
defense and cash to known terrorist
organizations the taliban haqqani and
isis k
and imagine if we as an american were to
send anything to a terrorist
organization a known terrorist
organization i mean he created what
president trump defeated with abu bakr
al-baghdadi i mean he's literally
creating isis and giving them the actual
ability to do it but that's what obama
did yeah exactly i mean
well i mean again
we keep saying obama but we already know
we're in obama 2.0 aren't right i mean
that's all we're looking at right now
doesn't obama have like property really
close to the white house too
you mean the office that biden just
occupies
i mean look we we know that obama is
sitting here shadow puppeting i mean
we're seeing the obama 2.0 model i i
don't think so i think he's being shadow
puppeted by different people oh it's
also other people don't get me wrong
what do you think obama's involvement is
i mean i think that you know he's
essentially telling joe biden that you
know all the things that i did my
administration i don't want them to be
wiped out i don't want all those
executive orders and all these things i
want my legacy to live on this isn't
about america this is about creating
legacies it's political football
everyone wants to go ahead and make the
next first down i don't know i think
obama just kind of want to get rich and
leave which he did that's what i think i
don't know if he has much of an interest
but let's go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and help support our
work over at timcast.com i know i've
seen a few of you mention having trouble
logging in if you're having any issues
send an email to members at timcast.com
and we'll immediately get back to you
the issue is that we recently did a
major upgrade to reduce the problems so
this means in the future there should be
less bugs but it means for now the jump
is going to result in some bugs so we
are working on it and uh we know there
are some issues but you just got to send
an email to members at timcast.com we'll
get you sorted
all right let's read some super chats we
got kyle pickett he says honkapalooza
festival 2022.
well all right then
all right
roberto lara says biden we need help at
the border biden goes huh say no more
voters everyone no wrong border joe
fact
christopher brem says florida seventh is
my district i'm excited to cast my vote
for corey very tired of being
represented by stephanie murphy thank
you so much absolutely stephanie murphy
is the person who portrays herself as an
actual moderate dem but she votes 98
percent of her time at pelosi and 94
percent of her votes is with aoc rashida
toleb ayana presley but yet she still
tries to run under the auspice that i'm
a
blue dog democrat
you are
her oh she is oh god i'm the furthest
thing from are you kidding me no i know
about that look you can call me a lot of
names but i can't believe that you
actually just said no you said who's you
said who's stephanie murphy you said i'm
a blue doctor i thought you were saying
oh god
that's what she's actually trying to
quote and claim but clearly she's not
all right
i can't pronounce that ziggs says is
everyone happy it looks like we're one
minute to midnight most people don't
even recognize it and we don't know who
is calling the shots in our government
one minute to midnight man you uh
i don't i don't know if that means
anything but uh
what's the what's that what's that great
quote from frank miller i imagine the a
a uh doomsday clock is as nourishing to
the intellect as a photograph of oxygen
to a drowning man
you ever hear that it's from uh that's
cool
yeah because they're always like frank
miller we're we're five minutes to
midnight and it's like it doesn't even
mean anything yeah right tomorrow's a
new day it's a bunch of people who are
like we're closer to the apocalypse sure
we are great
all right depends if you're asking al
gore or any of the climateist yeah
really let's talk about withdrawing that
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere
turning it into carbon by the wrapping
kill those cows murph says tim your
video on the inflation when you mention
the person who said they make more than
their parents when they were starting
out and can't afford rent it made me
wonder how much debt they had and what
what was on it it's just a viral meme i
mean i'm not even saying it's
necessarily like a real story it's
someone posting a meme but what they
were saying was
their parents were making like a
middle-class wage bought a house in in
the early 90s
now that house is worth you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars they're
making the equivalent buying power wise
of like double but the price of homes
are so high they can't even buy and the
cost of rent is higher than the the the
uh comparable cost of a mortgage that
their parents were paying
yeah and i think you can thank what
blackrock
yeah let's see who's got their hands and
everything state street and
vanguard
yep
when they buy up all the house and then
rent them out that's what you get
all right bobby bob says what is cory's
plans for big tech censorship
well let me just tell you right now the
first thing i'm going to do is look at
repealing section 230. i mean look the
bottom line is that we have to stop
these platforms we and i know there's an
argument on this i talked to
him i was going to push back a little
bit i i know what you're getting ready
to push back on but the bottom line is
is that we can't allow platforms to
continue to go ahead and censor just one
side we can't continue to allow it have
a singular narrative that's being spun
in an effort to try and influence or
control elections or trying to actually
you know promote an outcome that isn't
favorable to every single american so
this means we need the enforcement of
section 230 not great you're appealing
of it so the issue is or the rewriting
to ensure that it's just not the biggest
thing is that i think that people who
are being censored should have a right
to be able to go ahead and issue a civil
lawsuit against these businesses but
they're protected and that's one of the
issues i would i would actually be open
to repealing it uh only because it's a
scorched earth policy but i'll tell you
what happens right now
so uh
twitter
has pornography on their platform and
they're allowed in the app store
minds.com
gets booted from the app store for like
one image one time
so it's it's the issue is that they use
section 230 as legal protection
and it's it's they support their friends
and they shut down the little guy on our
website on timcast.com we have to abide
by the rules of our partner
organizations even though we're not
responsible for any user generated
content or words spoken in a news report
that's not indicative of something we've
said right although
to a certain degree like like quotes
like if someone if we're quoting someone
you can't come after come after us for
that the problem is
google
says to us
you have no protections under section
230 we do
so the law is granting the monopolies
and the big corporations all of these
protections and then they use their
power to shut down anyone who opposes
them because they control the system
so what we need is and again i still
think that we should be breaking up
these technocrats who are trying to
basically come in and censor and only
control one side
you know i think rumble is doing a
really good job i mean look what's
happening to oan as an example oem's at
a fantastic news station and they're
getting de-platformed non-stop
i think rumble is uh i'm fairly
optimistic i think these big tech
platforms are nuking themselves
facebook's stock drops 30 percent their
growth is in the gutter i look at uh you
know i've been telling people this if
you want to get started making videos or
podcasts go to rumble there's a bit that
you will your channel channel will grow
faster on rumble than youtube and you're
not going to get banned agreed it's not
even worth it to be on youtube for the
most part we're only here mostly because
we've been here you know and we do
upload our content to to rumble
plus we use their infrastructure i was
thinking if we tried to break up the
corporations like facebook into like six
smaller corporations facebook prime
facebook messenger instagram etc
zuckerberg would still have all the code
private he could just spin up new [ __ ]
with it was pardon me and uh that's my
one per month and uh so what if we can
force them to free their software code
so that other people have access to the
technology
i still think that the best thing to do
is be able to make it to where if you
are an individual who is censored and
you feel that it's a result of you being
a conservative you being you know i've
been censored by twitter in the past for
example i mean they still won't verify
me imagine that even though i follow all
their rules um i think that you should
be able to file a civil suit against
them and i think that eventually it'll
get so expensive for them to continue to
fight these battles that at that stage
because again these big corporations
these technocrats who are trying to
control and make that influence you have
to hit them where it hurts the most and
that's financially in their pockets yeah
all right turk longwell says cory sir
why so many based politicians in florida
and what's up with the three pins you
are wearing hoorah devil dog here i
don't want a civil war well the reason
we're so based in florida is because
florida is america i mean look
we're not sitting here with the same
censorship one of the things that makes
us great is tremendous leaders like
governor desantis i mean that's the
biggest thing as for the pens uh let's
see i've got my airborne wings i've got
my bronze star and my combat medical
badge for when i was deployed to combat
so uh just representing and trying to
ensure that i uh you know show for my
vets did you make a lot of jumps in the
airborne i did how many
um
well if you talk to an actual like world
war ii veteran because i got set up on
this one time i was sitting at the
all-american week one time and i had
this this old guy come up and he goes
how many jumps do you have and at the
time i was a young specialist i had like
33 jumps i'm like that he goes wow
because i only have three and i thought
to myself how do you have three and i i
learned the setup he goes yeah so
operation market garden nine megan and
at that point i was like sir what would
you like to drink yeah so
when it comes to that question if it's
if it's for combat zero thank you yeah
so so
where's that change from did they back
in the day would only reference the
actual combat missions that was just the
old guy setting me up and the young guy
getting what he deserved that that was
like pulling out the challenge coin
right there i was like sir how many
drinks would you like and i'll be buying
all night that's a good one
all right
dixie um
miss normis first name dixie says slash
the tires truck driver here those tires
are 100 plus psi even if you could slash
it with the hand tool you'll have your
arm de-gloved honk i guess they don't
teach that at harvard this lady
i mean yeah honestly there's a video i
watched if there's a big rig and a tire
blew out yeah and like the guy got
knocked back like
50 feet or something just like thrown
back this lady
you shouldn't be telling someone's going
to do it some stupid person's going to
be like
[Music]
i wonder if they'll uh ban her channel
on incitement or her twitter account on
incitement i'd hold my breath or
something like that yeah harvard
professor yeah brilliant and and she's
obviously clearly on the left yeah
this is uh this is who is teaching the
people who go to harvard so that's why
we talk about the indoctrination of
these higher ivy league schools we have
uh dylan massey who says i haven't
watched a member segment in a couple of
months i pay for the membership to
support the cause keep it the good work
tim commenting from the middle of ga
marjorie taylor green is the best rep of
my lifetime i'm a big fan she's great
she's yeah she's fantastic she's really
nice we have great conversations and boy
does the media smear her relentlessly
and and it's and so much bs they're
they're coming after she said gazpacho
and i'm like that's not relevant to
politics in any way i think it's stupid
you know what i really like about her is
the fact that she got called out for
that gaffe lots of politicians made caps
she laughed about it when she was on the
show i i really do like her yeah the
fact that you have a political leader
who's actually going to poke fun at
themselves for something they got called
out for doing is really unprecedented no
one makes more gaffes than joe biden
let's just be clear and the media will
cover for him left right and center they
translate for him yes they do they do
that's true what joe meant to say what
well no they do this i love it because
even conservatives do this joe biden
will come out and he'll be like
we got a
you know you know we got a economy uh
and we gotta improve the economy uh for
for uh kids because uh
anyway that was actually way too
coherent and that's more like what
happened orange the media ice cream the
media then right so we need to improve
the economy for our kids they cut out
all the all the bunk all the bs and they
just write simple words and i'm like he
never said those words this is a classic
thing the media will do if if they're
reporting on a statement from somebody
who they don't like they include um and
uh and every little gaff and they'll put
little dot dot dots in there put little
periods in there to indicate that the
person may be trailed off but if it's
someone they like they clean it up make
it sound really nice so i wanna i wanna
just say to uh to dylan who is a member
um by being a member but also not
watching i just to say see that's
i preferred if you watch the member
segments i think they're fantastic but
then it uh it actually costs us money
every time someone watches a member
segment because it's private proprietary
unlike youtube or whatever so uh not
only are you supporting the cause it's
very cheap for us because you're not
costing us any money but i will say if
you guys really want to support our work
we are um we do have sponsors we
periodically read but uh we are are
principally funded by memberships and so
the more people who sign up the more we
can expand the more people we can hire
the more we can budget and we are doing
that we have a new building being built
in west virginia
it's going to be amazing we're actually
planning on setting up some kind of um
private club for our members so there
will be on this free on freedom stand
like a club private club with like a bar
and games you can come hang out and
we're thinking of using nfts as like
your membership cards or however but as
we're talking about right now and there
will be a discord along with it really
excited for that and it's all possible
because you guys help support us over at
timcast.com as members and we're
actually planning on
having these streams on the website and
everything as well
all right let's see what we got
lewis says ian i deeply respect and
despite the harsh words you get from the
chat you always voice your opinion
without trying to mold yourself to the
in-group thank you so much
yeah yeah
it's true it's like um when you get
criticism positive or negative try what
i try to do is not take it personally
but listen to it and and understand it
and then see try to look for some
because there's you almost always some
value in criticism
yeah well no i i also want to say that i
really do admire that too the fact that
you you don't really let it get to you
when you do get negative comments i
think that's cool and the fact that like
even though you do disagree with a lot
of people in the chat you still sort of
come on and voice your but the thing
that's great about him is that he's
open-minded enough to at least one give
them the opportunity to speak and two
you take it in you actually analyze it
and go okay well maybe this is a pretty
good point i still don't agree with you
100 on it but like you're open you're
open-minded unlike the left who is so
intolerant that if you don't actually
say and utilize the exact same narrative
as they use you just continually attack
and respond so yeah hats off to you on
that but i think a lot of people too
also don't understand because you know
there's there's periodic adrian curry in
the chat saying ian is awesome you see
you see ian
needs to be here because otherwise we'd
be just another run-of-the-mill
political talk shows you'd be in a sound
vacuum there's got to be there's got to
be more unique perspectives and so
that's one thing that you know ian
brings when he when he arbitrarily goes
off on rants about aliens or magnetic
fields and for all you critics out there
i will re-watch the show and be like
shut up ian because sometimes i'll talk
when i want to hear the other the
brilliant guests you know and the other
awesome hosts
but it is good to have um
you know there there's there's very
homogenized political voices in the
space and for whatever reason ian is
this like completely
separate
you know perspective on everything so it
works out helping us see things we don't
normally see ourselves even if sometimes
we think it's dumb
you got to have that man also i knew it
was good when he came out and he had no
shoes on oh yeah
i'm sitting cross-legged right now also
ian lent me an air mattress he used to
not even get dressed he wears his
pajamas and i was like yo yeah
and oh and i was like what does it
matter what i wear tim and i was like oh
yeah what does it water matter whatever
what i wear so i just wear whatever
that's i was like well i was like that
makes sense i was like you gotta put on
pants yeah and i was like okay so then
the point was trying to say that a
little bit
right i was like what does it matter
what i wear dude and then i thought
about it i was like that's a good pointy
and what does it matter so just wear
what he's asking you to wear who gives a
you know well it's just because like
you know when we have like messy hair
and my pajamas and then we've got like
steve bannon coming in and like alex
jones donald trump's coming over and
we're like yeah it's like like ian's in
his words
it was one thing when it was like we
weren't really having that many guests
this is something i've thought of it's
almost like i'm more encouraged to wear
dirty jeans five days in a row than
clean pajamas every day yep which is
very weird because it becomes about
optics but that's not i mean that's not
necessarily the dichotomy you could wear
clean jeans every day yeah
that's an option for you
and we love you i like i said there was
um for those who didn't hear i mean ian
ian has lent me an air mattress to sleep
on it
yeah yeah all right good guy much
appreciated man all right let's read
some more let's read some more we got uh
storm viking says tim the boomers are
lost and stuck in the 70s they think the
economy is booming and biden has the
greatest job growth in us history i
shake my head at my grandparents every
time i'm around them tell them to stop
watching cnn
or msnbc or most of your mainstream
media
steve says we really are in world war
three the two sides are freedom and
authoritarianism the authoritarians
already won they own every single
institution i disagree they may own many
of them but they're losing them and it's
laughably bad i mean the freedom convoy
they're they're the freak out over this
is is hilarious biden calls trudeau and
he's like you got to stop this and then
trudeau's like i you better get out of
here or else and the truckers are like
no
and then nothing out they can't do
anything about it or like you just
talked about before with facebook uh
facebook's uh huge drop i mean thirty
percent thirty percent drop yeah it's
massive also i mean the thing the left
wants you to believe is that they've won
that's what all their propaganda is
oriented towards making you believe they
want you to think that everyone agrees
with them and that's standing up to them
is futile and unfortunately
conservatives play into it because we'll
see something which is legitimately
upsetting such as them trying to you
know promote the gay agenda through
their advertisements and then we go oh
my gosh it's done it's over they've won
no there's still a lot of pushing back
that we're able to do if we're willing
to really unify and boycott the
companies that support these ridiculous
left-wing agendas try to vote on the
proper politicians and also most
importantly speak
up when we are around people even if we
are not sure that they will agree with
us yeah i'm all about people educating
themselves i mean this is the problem
the only time that this misinformation
propaganda warfare succeeds is when you
fail to be able to research and look for
the truth yourself i mean that's really
where people that's where china has
preyed upon things i mean even the other
day steve bannon and maureen bannon had
used one of my tweets because remember
when the the hhs said that the reason
for the cuban uprising was because there
wasn't enough vaccinations i mean
these are the things where you know i
came forward and i said oh great peace
by the misinformation propaganda wing of
you know the us government i mean
research find the truth you know what i
used to love doing in chicago during the
obama years
i'd be walking down the street with a
friend and then as soon as someone some
stranger was getting with an earshot i
would go yeah oh just me to turn to my
friend and say you know i know but obama
did bomb and kill all those kids as we
walk past them it's like i want them to
hear that i'm not going to confront them
on it i'm not going to say to him i just
want that to be said as they walked past
and now that's literally his job this is
like what you've done for career like
i'm going to make sure these people hear
this this is funny like tim castle
literally tim tim got his start walking
down the street saying these things i
love it well it's because i was doing
the nonprofit stuff where like we got on
the street and we'd fundraise and so i
would just be like
it's an interesting situation for
someone if you're walking down the
street minding your own business and
then you hear someone say something i'm
not challenging them i'm not arguing
with them i'm not trying to make them
believe it it's just something i said so
my idea there was hopefully that person
just goes is that true was that guy who
is that guy and then they look it up and
go whoa he did kill kids well there's
the unfortunate obama did bomb kids once
i wonder and it's well it's unfortunate
but
for as much as i like trump he's
definitely the favorite president of my
life i'm now to be fair i'm only 26 here
right that's not saying much but
he continued a lot of that too i mean
for example we were talking about yemen
earlier he kept us there
it's very disappointing
i got to read something now i think
there's an argument to be made that he
was not able to do a lot of the things
he would wanted to have done because of
the deep state operating against him but
let's still flag that let's read some
more super chats we got tony he says
with the first link the chain is forged
the first speech censured the first
thought forbidden the first freedom
denied chains us all irrevocably
it is a brilliant quote
and uh it's from star trek the next
generation
it's very good
david says with kinzinger stating his
belief it will come down to his two
targeted assassinations which side is
more likely to take the extreme action i
could be wrong but i believe he's
planting a seed i don't know uh
i don't know if it's irrelevant
the main point is people are going to
fight you know that's the point of the
civil war well and as i talked about
before it's not like what he's saying
hasn't already occurred we watched this
with representative steve scalise
tom's pants says amir lock reached for
and picked up the gun after the police
announced upon entry clearly visible
even in the video tyt lied about i don't
know if i agree with that he's under the
covers i don't know what he's doing it
was nine seconds and additionally
look i think the police slide
i don't think we have all the details
i'm not going to fall for this but uh
look when the police come in and are
yelling i have no idea what they're
saying i mean you said you heard what
they were saying i can't tell i mean i
heard it very clearly i mean they they
were clearly saying that you know search
warrant and show your hands i mean
that's i i i i definitely could hear it
i don't i don't think it matters i mean
if i'm gonna rob someone's house i'm
gonna yell that agrees if you know
burglar wants to invade your home while
you're sleeping they're gonna yell
police nobody move they do it all the
time actually it's a big problem
so
look man no knock warrants i agree with
you know rand paul introduced that bill
he was trying to get no knock warrants
banned or whatever i think they're
unconstitutional i also think the young
turks are our liars i believe they lie a
lot so um i think that we've seen that
with the nunc warrants in most cases it
usually ends up in a way that it's hard
to determine who's at fault
and i mean i would support the idea of
getting rid of no knock warrants i mean
rylo says ian stop trying to rationalize
the motivations of the left while they
are punching you in the face you're in a
fight because the left said you are
fight back any way you can or you will
be asleep if it was a situation where we
were literally in a physical fight i
would fight back but we're still in the
demo we're still in the diplomatic phase
and and people emotionally charged can
be communicated with trust so you need
to read the art of war man because you
are you are victim to so much but how do
you know i'm telling the truth right now
what do you mean i'm dude i'm a maniac
actor dude
what does that do with what you do i'm
here to manipulate people bro why why
would you say that because are you
writing the truth how do you how can you
tell it's like pretending
my goal is to help people and i think
that communication is the best way and
that is my my hill
you got a guy who keeps coming up and
stealing from your garden and you say
well they're not fighting me so i'm fine
with it no stealing is a form of
fighting yeah i think that is well
they're stealing from you every day bro
i love the way you think tim what do you
mean like man i mean look at that
federal reserve you complain i don't
think we can invisible taxation through
inflation i don't think we can
physically fight the military industrial
complex people are posting ones
no some people posted some 20s thanks
guys so in dungeon and dragons when you
roll a one it's like absolute failure
abject failure in a 20 is like total
success so when ian says something it's
a one or a 20. but i also went to like
liberal arts college with a bunch of
these people that were talking about the
leftists like this is my my people and i
know they can be communicated with they
just do it emotionally instead of
logically
i actually agree i actually agree with
the emotional versus logic thing i have
to read this one but you might not like
it it's critical
of course it is howard says your guest
is worse than congressman dan crenshaw
i don't really know how to answer to
that considering considering that i'm an
anti-interventionist and considering
that i would never vote for red flag
laws and that i actually own
one of only like what three a5 warhead
presses in america that helps to support
like our military and our law
enforcement for trainings and things
like that
crenshaw canceled on us twice oh well of
course he would because he doesn't want
to actually come on and have to debate i
mean maybe he's busy i want him on
that's why i said that i mean i'm not
here to disrespect him for not coming on
my show it's like you don't have to come
on my show it's a favor to me and to
everybody but we we invited him out he
said maybe someday he eventually said
sure then he canceled because he said we
had a vote then he said i'll reschedule
for next week and then he said
scheduling conflict can't come
so would you describe yourself as a
non-interventionist yeah i don't think i
i would describe myself as an america
first conservative i mean i think that
us trying to involve ourselves in
foreign wars has nothing to do with us
does not threaten the homeland does not
threaten our constitutional liberties
and freedoms and the idea that we should
be securing our own borders before we're
worried about canada and ukraine and all
the other nations yeah i think that i
would definitely describe myself as an
america first agenda i mean domestic
production domestic growth i mean it's
not going to need to be i i would agree
with you that that's what our policy
should be but earlier it seemed as if
you were defending our our uh role in
yemen maybe i misunderstood no it wasn't
defending our role in yemen i was
talking about the role that we played
okay and see this is the thing you need
to understand too telling someone the
truth about what's going on it's like
you know if ian comes out and says
everything that's happening there we're
doing is bad and then you're like well
actually here's what's really happening
that's not supportive of it i was simply
just telling you i mean you did describe
the the death of the children as
collateral damage because unfortunately
this is why i am an anti-interventionist
and i don't like wars because again who
who wants peace more than the people who
actually have to fight these things yeah
of course you know i mean i've been
involved in many of these wars and many
of these conflicts and i've seen where
collateral damage is actually occurring
i've seen in the streets of iraq where a
firefight goes off and there's innocent
families who are being killed so and and
calling something collateral damage
doesn't mean you're supporting it so
here's my point in reference to i think
well i think what you're absolutely
right about is that people who have
served in the military and seen conflict
tend to be the most anti-war all of my
friends who are the most anti-war
veterans they're actually the people who
convinced me to take the positions i
have my point is just that i think one
thing that we fell at as conservatives
very often is we use the language of the
left and we use the language of our
adversaries and we'll play into their
euphemisms and i think collateral damage
is one of those euphemisms
so what do we say the innocent that are
being killed i would say so yeah i mean
at the end of the day it's it you also
have to understand that military
vernacular and the way that we speak in
the military we're very like
acronym-based and we utilize things that
we learn collateral damage is a term
that we utilize in the military and it's
something that we talk about all the
time and so for me it's just a very
familiar term that's fair that then we
misunderstood each other i would say
that i would argue that there is is
better terminology to use i understand
based on your background and why you'd
be more likely to i would encourage
people to refer to it as the death of
innocent children all right darius says
tim typically new jersey police make an
average 123 thousand dollars a year 34k
is showing as minimum and it is likely
just court police making the small
amount while retired
well there you go interesting that's why
they'll they'll do it
so high i mean
you know i new jersey's a corrupt dirty
state it's like two illinois is worse
you got that little new york armpit of
high industry and then you've got the
rest of the state which is like and why
do they have the same laws it makes no
sense i kind of understand not concealed
carry in a densely urban area how do you
feel about that
again i don't know enough about new
jersey politics and about how like
things are working there from the law
enforcement perspective but i mean i i'm
still trying to process the fact of 120
something thousand because i got a buddy
of mine who's on the swat team there in
st john's county in florida and he's
making like 47 to 50. wow
i mean it's insane i i still can't
believe that ponton says this here is
what is not cool wasting super chat time
talking about ian with high dollar topic
relevant chats go in the trash
really needs fixing
we don't choose super chats based on
price for the most part we do tend to
read higher super chats more than lower
ones but um
my goal is not to make it so that people
who can't afford super chats get ignored
sometimes i'm i'm i'm a super chat
communist in that regard i said i'm i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm more of like a
democratic socialist supercharger like
still a little bit of capitalism in
there you know i if someone does give us
a lot of money i want to make sure we
we're going to respect and support that
but not every person some people will
give high dollar super chats with really
awful comments and some people with five
bucks have some of the best so we try to
we try to you know balance it out yeah i
was thinking is there something i could
do that would help this show get more
popular faster and i'm trying like am i
slowing it down by talking you gotta get
ripped god i'm gonna get ripped you guys
oh you're right actually i can wear
cleaning jeans yeah just one day ian's
wearing like a really tight tank top or
whatever and he's just like bulging
muscles like carrot top you're right i
was thinking that this voice drops
when you're in good shape because it's
like you know that person has discipline
i want i want to be like that person
what if like in three months ian's super
ripped and his head's shaved and he's
got like no no beard his voice is
dropped i want to be back for the first
all right let's see armor gesture says
ladies and gents we got ian to see the
light
thank you there you go i love you
all right
it's jeremy says tim would you consider
a major fundraise via gibson to go to
take on larger projects like movies or
documentaries yes absolutely we need to
get to that point i think once we get
the new new facility set up
um i've i've thought about it you know
we had um nick cersei on the show he's
been in a bunch of you know big movies
and tv shows he was unjustified and i
asked him like how much does it cost to
do like one of these documentaries or
films and he's like a million bucks and
i'm like okay we'd have to do a
fundraiser for that
that's a lot of money and uh if we have
people who are pitching us and they want
to do it and we think we can do it it's
not just about the good pitch we need
the great producers and directors
and then once we have that plan
okay let's do a fundraiser for it but i
mean you look at um gosnell that film
they did it was four million dollars a
four million dollar budget that's a lot
of money man it's crazy i'm like how do
you even get that money
so
maybe you know we're looking at much
smaller productions like a hundred grand
you know maybe maybe some documentaries
and things like that but yeah well we
can definitely do some fundraisers to it
for people who are interested
all right let's see
chief strider says tim the civil war
hawk did you know that the truckers
blocking the border and commerce can be
viewed as an act of domestic terror
which would give the government the
opening to use the military yes that's
literally why they're doing it and um i
think it's a peaceful protest but
what do you know man i don't know
all right let's just read one more we
got crypto daddy says from west virginia
lost my job for refusing to wear a mask
after i had coveted and vaxxed weren't
required union rep and supervisor were
related lied about what happened would
love to tell my story and in turn
uh send an email to spin the ufo
gmail.com and again this is one of the
things that i'm really really against
and and
these unconstitutional mandates
you know i just i i cannot support when
you're watching your first responders
who are being terminated for not taking
these vaccinations or you're putting
people into a position or a predicament
where it's either you keep you know you
have to make the decision do i take a
vaccination that i don't really want to
take in order to feed my family or do i
stand on my principles and then i have
to worry about putting food on the table
for my kids no american should have to
come to that medical choice is a real
thing and we need to be supporting that
right on all right everybody if you
haven't already smash that like button
one like equals one honk go to
timcast.com help support our work sign
up become members you'll get access to a
huge library of members only content we
also have the green room show which has
your favorite people behind the scenes
candid just hanging out having a drink
maybe definitely want to check that out
and uh smash the like button like i said
subscribe share the share with your
friends you can follow the show at
timcast irl on instagram or anywhere
else you can follow me at timcast on
instagram or anywhere else you want to
shout anything out corey yeah i mean i
just wanted to tell everybody one thanks
for having me on the show what a
fantastic show i love it i want to
continue to support the platform i
definitely want to make sure that we're
always maintaining free speech i mean
it's one of the things i'm big on uh for
those who are listening if you like
anything i had to say please join me at
uh on my twitter handle which is you
know at corey mills fl or go to our
campaign website which is
mils4florida.com
right on beautiful yeah thank you so
much for coming on um and if if you guys
want to check my work out you can look
at freedom tunes we upload animated
political satire every thursday released
a video two days ago called fed talks
think you all will enjoy it is it mills
for freedom the number four or the worst
no so it's
millsforflorida.com and again proud to
say we're the most nationally endorsed
candidate right now and we'll be
speaking at cpac and just endorsed by
acu
so the the conservative union actually
just endorsed us so i'm really really
proud and thanks to matt schlapp the
board and acu for you know finding the
confidence in me to be able to go
forward and be a constitutionalist and
fight for american freedoms great to see
you man awesome to meet you really look
forward to seeing you again
wear a new pair of clean jeans it's not
going to
happen get ripped and wear a tank top
i am going to do that though
follow me ian crossland.net i'll catch
you guys next week thank you guys for
tuning in this evening you may follow me
on twitter and minds.com at
sourpatchlids head over to
youtube.com forward slash cast castle
because we put up a vlog episode every
day and you can watch the shenanigans
that's occurring here at the castle it's
a semi-fictional vlog we do bits it's
funny you'll love it sheamus was
torturing people so check it out thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all
next time
you